>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> JANICE HYDE: Good morning.
And welcome to the John W. Kluge
Center at the Library of Congress.
I'm Janice Hyde, Intern Director of
the Kluge Center, which is delighted
to serve as the host for today's
symposium, Saving the Web,
the Ethics and Challenges of
Preserving What's on the Internet.
Before we begin, please take a
moment to silence your cellphones
and other electronic devices.
Thank you.
Today's program is being recorded
for the Library of Congress
and Kluge Center websites.
As well as for future placement
on the library's YouTube
and iTunes channels.
We're also living Tweeting
this event.
So if you would like
to tweet, retweet,
or just follow the Twitter
conversation please do
so using hashtag save the web.
The Kluge Center brings
together scholars and researchers
from around the world to exchange
ideas and energize one another.
To distill wisdom from the library's
rich resources and to interact
with policymakers and the public.
It also administers the Kluge
Prize, periodically conferred
by the Librarian of Congress to
recognize lifetime achievement
in the study of humanity.
To learn more about it's
programs and opportunities,
please visit the center's
website at loc.gov/kluge.
For the past few months, the Kluge
Center has been privileged to have
in residence Dame Wendy Hall,
who has served as the Kluge chair
in technology and society.
The chair in technology and society
is a senior scholar position,
focusing on the impact
of fast changing technology
on human societies.
The scholar makes use of
rapidly growing digital resources
of the Library of Congress,
augmented by science
and technology data and
documentation from around the world.
Today's symposium helps mark the
culmination of Wendy's research
and reflection while at the center.
And we are honored to
have served as her host.
It is now my pleasure to
welcome to the podium,
someone who is intimately familiar
with the management of vast amounts
of information on a daily basis.
David Mao currently
leads the institution
as the acting Librarian of Congress.
He previously served as the
Deputy Librarian of Congress.
And prior to that he was the
23rd Law Librarian of Congress.
In that position, he expanded
the Law Library's collections,
especially its rare
books, supported efforts
to make US public domain legal
materials accessible online
and brought to the
library a 1215 Magna Carta
for an historic exhibition
to commemorate the great
charter's 800th anniversary.
Please join me in welcoming
David Mao.
[ Applause ]
>> DAVID S. MAO: Thank
you so much Janice
and good morning to all of you.
As Janice said, I have
the privilege as serving
as the acting Library of Congress.
And one of the joys of
being the acting Librarian
of Congress is I get
to welcome groups.
And I'm really excited
to be able to welcome all
of you to the library today.
I understand over the last two days
many of you here have participated
in a datathon here, which Dame Wendy
Hall, along with her colleagues,
Ian Milligan who is
here and Matt Weber,
and Jimmy Lynn have
helped coordinate and all
of you have participated in this
exciting event here at the library.
And it was developed
with the generous support
from the National Science
Foundation, the Social Sciences
and Humanities Research Council
of Canada, the Internet Archive,
Rutgers University, and
the University of Waterloo.
So, we thank all of them for helping
to support this program
here at the library.
We, at the library are
cohosting this event along;
I'm sorry I should say the
library is hosting this event
with several cohosts
from within the library.
Janice mentioned the John W. Kluge
Center, but I would like also
to mention a couple
of other entities here
at the library that
have participated.
The Law Library of Congress,
Library's National
Digital Initiative Office
and the Web Archiving Program.
Now, web archiving is
nothing new to the library.
In fact, we've had a program
here since about 2000.
And over the last 15 or 16 years
we've unmasked quite a bit of data,
as you can imagine, a lot.
And we're not exactly sure
what we're doing with it,
in the sense that there is
just a lot of challenges,
and so it's particularly timely
that we have this datathon,
and in fact this symposium
today to talk
about the issues associated
with web archiving.
The datathon yesterday and the
day before provided an opportunity
to explore our cutting-edge research
tools and also the development
of a broad-based consensus on
how we can approach this issue.
And so today you will hear the
culmination of those two days
of talking and discussing.
And you also hear from a panel of
experts on some additional ideas.
And so hopefully this will just
generate some good thoughts moving
forward and continue
moving us forward.
And we would not be able to do this
of course without Dame Wendy Hall
And so it is my pleasure
now to be able
to provide a brief introduction,
although I know she doesn't need
an introduction to any of you.
We are just very, very honored that
she was able to be in residence here
at the library for the
last couple of months.
She's brought with her terrific
energy, intellect, good will.
And we are very, very grateful that
she has spent the time and helped us
to coordinate this event.
So, the datathon and today's
events I think are a testament
to your expertise.
Because she's been able to gather
a group of high profile thinkers
from various disciplines across the
world to talk about saving the web.
And that's really what we
really need to talk about.
And it's a pressing challenge
for us here at the library,
institutions around the world,
cultural institutions as we try
and think about how we are going to
preserve all of this information.
Just a brief snapshot
of her background.
She's a professor of a computer
science at the University
of Southampton in England.
She's a pioneer in research
and an early collaborator
with Tim Berners-Lee on
the development of the web,
which build on the work of Vint
Cerf, who we're very, very delighted
to be able to welcome
to the Library today.
Her work as been at the
forefront of computer science,
multimedia and hypermedia.
The semantic web, and
digital libraries.
And she's done this
for quite some time.
Almost 30 years I think.
[ Laughter ]
So, here at the Library
she has been working
on a project titled Internet
Histories and Futures.
And on that project, she's been
using the library's collections
to explore the economic,
social and technical dimensions
that have contributed to
the development of the web
as a social technical system.
She's been the Senior Vice President
of the Royal Academy of Engineering,
a member of the UK Prime Minister's
Council for Science and Technology,
a founding member of
the Scientific Council
of the European Research Council,
a fellow of the Royal Society,
and most importantly
she is a Dame Commander
of the Order of the British Empire.
So please join me in
welcoming Dame Wendy.
[ Applause ]
>> DAME WENDY HALL:
Thank you very much.
Thank you so much, David.
I don't want to take a lot of
your time I want to thank David
and everyone at the Library of
Congress and the Kluge Center
for making me so welcome.
For really helping with this event,
which we hope will be sentinel
in the development of this
world, this new world.
And I've had a wonderful time and
there will always be a special place
in my heart now for the
Library of Congress and I hope
to come back many times and visit.
It's my, you'll hear a
bit more from me later.
But it's my privilege now to
not stand very long between you
and your first keynote
speaker, Vint Cerf,
who doesn't need an
introduction, you have all our bios
for the speakers today on
the, well except one, Abbie.
But, you have the bio of Vint.
Now, here, we wouldn't be here today
talking about this if it wasn't
for people like Vint
Cerf and Bob Kahn.
And I don't think people realize how
unbelievably seminal their work was
in creating the open
and free internet.
And it's always in parallel
with the different forces on it.
And we have to continue to
support the efforts of the people.
Still led by Vint and
Bob, who work hard
to keep the internet alive for us.
It's a very short time
in the period of history.
When you look at what's happened,
you know what's here in the library
and other institution libraries
around the world, you know we are,
it's only decades since
we've had this.
This is a blink of the eye in terms
of civilization, and we really,
really have to make sure
that we preserve its openness
and its freedom for
the future of humanity.
Now, Vint has, because of his
work, is very well honored.
He has received many
awards and metals.
He's met every president,
every head of state, I think.
He can outdo me on name
dropping [laugther] and that's;
I've never met the Emperor of Japan.
But, the wonderful thing about
Vint is he's still giving back.
The fact that he's here today,
he's been on the west coast,
we were out there, we've both
recently been presidents of the ACM.
We were out there for the big
ACM Council and Awards Banquet.
He only flew back yesterday, and
tomorrow he goes to Barcelona,
and yet he's found time to come
here this morning to talk to us,
because I know on everything else
he does, he's absolutely passionate
about preserving the content that is
being put onto this amazing system
that he and others created.
So, without further ado, it's my
pleasure to introduce Vint Cerf.
[ Applause ]
>> VINT CERF: Good morning
ladies and gentlemen.
And thank you very much Wendy
for a very friendly introduction.
I always get nervous when people
clap before you've said anything.
It makes me feel like
I should just sit
down because it won't
get any better than that.
I have the sad duty to tell
you that Bob Kahn is not going
to be able to join us today.
His sister passed away on Monday
and he is in Cleveland seeing to all
of the things associated with that.
He passes along his
regrets and hopes
that there'll be another
opportunity for him to join us.
I will try to offer some information
that Bob would have given.
I won't do it with
nearly the same panache
that bob does, but I'll do my best.
So, let me start, assuming I can
get this thing to behave properly.
All right for our next
trick ladies and gentlemen.
Let's see.
There we go.
So, I want to introduce
a term digital vellum.
And I want to explain that it isn't
just about the physical median.
This is an environment that I
would like to see become real.
And it has a great deal to
do with the preservation
of information associated with
online and digital content.
So, let me begin by observing,
oh maybe it doesn't want to.
What does that mean?
It has frozen.
So, that's the end of my talk.
I guess that's it [laugther].
Let's try.
Wow, this, oh here we go.
Now it's waking up.
All right I don't know why the
other little arrows didn't work.
But anyway.
So, let me first of
all draw your attention
to something you already know and
you've spent 2 days talking about.
And I'm sorry I wasn't
here to participate.
And that's, this is a huge problem,
and the scope is quite dramatic.
For one thing, we have all
these digital structures
and they're complex, they
have many representations.
We need vocabulary in order
to talk about this stuff.
We need identifier spaces
in order to make reference
to these digital objects that
we're trying to hang on to.
And we have to resolve
those references
to the actual object themselves.
The irony of the Worldwide Web
is that the domain name system
and the URLs that are derived
from the domain names are
not necessarily stable.
As you know if you fail to pay
your annual fee for registration
that domain name may go away,
and all the URLs associated
with it may also become unreachable.
Everybody here has experienced
404, you know site not found.
So, we need to do something
about that.
Bob Kahn has this digital object
architecture, which I will talk
about later, has the
unfortunate acronym of DOA.
I thought maybe he ought to
come out with something else.
But in any case, it's a
very thoughtful mechanism
for preserving identifiers
over long periods of time
that are not changing, that are
not reassigned, they're stable.
We plainly need standards in order
to preserve this digital content.
And the ingestion process to
bring in digital objects needs
to be pretty rigorous, because
we have to capture a great deal
of metadata associated
with this to acquisition.
There are also these really
interesting legal questions
that arise having to
do with copyright,
not only on the objects themselves
or patents on the software used
to render the objects and
licensing and other kinds of things.
I think that the copyright
laws should be amended in order
to give rights to agencies like
the Library of Congress that are
in the business of
digital preservation.
We have this fair use
notion here in the US
and I think a preservation
arrangement also ought
to be incorporated
into our thinking.
And finally, we need business
models to retain this vast
and increasing amount of digital
content over long periods of time.
And here I'm not talking
about decades,
I'm talking about centuries.
And business models for
centuries are hard to come by.
I can think of a few, there are some
breweries that have been around for
about 4 or 500 hundred years.
And of course, there's always
the Catholic Church so, anyway.
The other thing which I
find very interesting is
that the OAIS definitions that
I'm sure you're all familiar
with have this interesting
recursive property
that you know you have these digital
representations of the objects
that you're preserving and there
are recursive references to this
until you get down to the point
where there's some specific group
whose domain knowledge is sufficient
to correctly interpret the content
that's being preserved and at
that point has to stop somewhere.
But the problem is the groups
that understand the details
may eventually die out,
in which case we may have to recur
once more in order to make sure
that subsequent users
have enough information
to correctly interpret the content.
So, there's a lot of
formality hiding in here,
but it's going to be necessary.
And of course, we'll have to
have all kinds of specializations
for representations for
particular kinds of data
and I include not simply documents
that you would typically find here
in this library, but also
scientific data, data collection
from space missions at
NASA and data coming
from the large hadron collider.
All of that stuff is digital
content worthy of preservation.
So, it needs to by systematic.
I'm not necessarily arguing that
the OAIS concepts are the only ones
that can be applied here.
But, they certainly are
representative of the style
that I think is necessary.
And within our own
research organizations here
in the United States, PCAST and
the OSTP have strongly recommended
that research sponsored by the US
government should incorporate saving
of the data, software and metadata
associated with that research
so that it can be made
available in perpetuity
to the future researchers.
I also think that if we're going to
build archives, we better build more
than one for the possibility
that only one goes away
and then everything is lost.
So, distributing the information
across multiple archives
strikes me as a wise move.
And finally, we need
policy frameworks
that will provide incentives
for people to build
and operate these archives.
So, let me switch gears
for a moment.
Move into some of the more
substantive questions.
One of them has to do with
how we archive static content.
Some of you will notice
that there are certain media
that are blasted for
quite a long time.
By accident in some cases like
these cuneiform tablets that were,
you know essentially made on clay.
Most of them were intended to be
reused, except the fires burned
down some of the archives and baked
the clay into its permanent form.
Which is why we still
have some of them.
Now, what I don't like about this is
preservation by accident [laugther].
I think that those of us in this
room should be paying attention
to preservation on purpose and we
should have ways of doing that.
Now, we've also seen
other documents.
Vellum for example is
quite a resilient material.
Which is why I thought the term
digital vellum captured a little bit
of that notion.
Unfortunately, I think that to
preserve all the digital information
on real vellum, it would
require a lot of goats and sheep.
And more than exist
even in New Zealand.
So, we need to do something
comparable with different media.
And we've all seen the accidental
preservation of [inaudible]
for example, because it happened
to have been stored in a cave
in a dessert where it was dry.
But, again, I don't want
preservation by accident.
Now, when digital technologies
emerged over the past 70 years,
people got very excited
because bits seemed
to have this ethereal
ability to just live forever.
After all, they're just
logical bits, right?
But they actually have
physical manifestations.
And I will tell you showing up here
at the Library of Congress a decade
and a half ago with some CD-ROMs,
thinking look at all
the data we can store
on such a small amount of space.
I'm so proud of myself.
And one of the librarians here
came back with a vellum manuscript.
It was 1000 years old, and still
as readable today as it was then.
And if you happen to speak, you
know in ancient Greek, etcetera.
And she said to me, and how long
will your polycarbonate CD-ROM last?
And of course, I didn't have
a very good answer for that.
It might only be 20 years
before it delaminates.
But the more severe
problem is that the reader
for it might not be
available for it either.
Not even in the Smithsonian,
or if it is it might
not be in workable form.
So, you see all these examples
of media that have come and gone.
If you buy Macintosh
equipment like I do,
you might have regretted discovering
that the latest versions don't
have a CD-ROM reader in them
at all to save space I guess.
But it means that my stack of media
that I carefully accumulated
is no longer useful
because I can't read it.
So, that's a serious problem.
And it gets worse.
I mean we have all these
other media, like YouTube,
and Flickr and Picasa and so on.
All these online media.
So, what I tell other audiences,
you know this as well as anyone,
but I try to give them a sense
for why this is important.
So, those of you, I hope who
have read, "A Team of Rivals"
by Doris Kearns Goodwin will have
noticed how well she reproduced the
conversations of the time.
It felt like she had
been a fly on the wall,
although we knew she
wasn't there in the 1860s.
So, how did she do that?
Well she ran around to I
don't know how many libraries.
I put 100 down here
just as a placeholder.
But she got the correspondence
of the principles in this story.
So, she knew what they
were talking about
and how they expressed themselves,
and what positions they took.
And she was able to
reproduce the conversations
in what I thought was
a very credible way.
So, imagine that you're a 22nd
century Doris Kearns Goodwin
and you're trying to
reproduce the tenner
of the times in the 21st century.
What will she find.
You know will the National
Archives have anything useful
to share with us?
What about all the
emails and the Tweets,
and the blogs and everything else.
Will any of that be
render-able in the 22nd century.
And the answer is we don't know.
And I think that we don't have
very good answers at this point.
And it gets even more complicated.
When you think about executable
content, this is not static stuff.
This requires interpretation
by software.
People are interacting with it.
It's not just games.
I mean there are other
kinds of applications too.
Things like spreadsheets and so on,
which are things you interact with.
A static version of the
spreadsheet is typically a snapshot
of its current values.
But the value of the spreadsheet is
the ability to put different values
in and have software run.
So, we have this executable
content that we have to think
about in the archival context.
So, there are a bunch of challenges.
And I suppose over the last
few days, you've been talking
about these and others,
but I will remind you
of the ones that come to my mind.
One is figuring out what
the bits mean at all.
The second one is the
metadata capture.
The third is hanging on to
executable code or source code
if we can get it and
then it's this question
of how do I figure out
how to run old code.
And I've been using kind
of sort of a metaphor here.
If you could take a
digital x-ray of a computer
when it has the operating system,
the application, the actual files
that its working on
plus the hardware,
and you could take a snapshot of
all that and then re-instantiate it
by emulating the hardware and
running the old operating system
and putting the application on it.
You might actually be able
to preserve the capability
to run all this old software
over long periods of time.
Of course, you also have to have a
place to store all of this stuff.
So, we have to have
affordable large scale memory.
Now, unfortunately, we live in a
world which is filled with change.
And one of the things is
that companies don't
necessarily last forever.
So, they go bankrupt.
And some of their assets
turn out to be things
that get sold to other people.
So, if a company goes bankrupt
that made the application software
that you use to produce new content,
and you say after the company
goes bankrupt, can I have a copy
of the program, can I
have the source code?
And the bankruptcy judge
says no unless you want
to pay $6 million for this asset.
So, or you have companies that just
say I can't support this anymore.
I'm not going to make it run.
It, being an application, run on
the current day's operating systems,
or next year's operating systems.
And now you're stuck,
because either you have
to keep using the old operating
system to use the old application,
or you have to hope somebody
can translate the documents
that you've produced, or the
object you produced into something
that het new software
will interpret.
And we know that not everybody
is going to pay attention
to backward compatibility.
So, there are really tough problems.
So, there's questions about who
owns the software in addition
to who owns the digital objects.
And under which circumstances
you have access to that software.
And so again I keep thinking
we need legal frameworks
that provide exceptions
for preservation purposes.
So, there is a project at
Carnegie Mellon, which I hope some
of you may already know
about, called Olive,
which is like the thing you
put in your cocktail glass.
This is being run, or was
run under in a self-support
by Mahadev Satyanarayanan.
We call him Satya for
obvious reasons.
And this was a very
successful effort
to essentially emulate old hardware
and run old operating
systems on the system.
Now, this is not easy.
It might sound like
it's easy, but it's not.
There's a whole lot of thing
that have to be emulated
or correctly identified
in order to make it work.
One of them is making sure you
understand exactly how the old
hardware works so you
can emulate exactly how
that hardware executes instructions
on a virtual environment.
Then you have to be able to
bring in the operating system
and the applications and so on.
And that includes all the library's
executable libraries that are needed
to make the applications work.
So, it just goes on and on.
Language settings have to
be known I mean like what
if this is an application
that was you know written
for Bulgarian instead of English
or French, or something else.
So, there's a whole lot of
details that have to be remembered
and replicated in order
to make this stuff work.
And that's why this term digital
x-ray seemed so attractive.
Now, what was very interesting
is that he said well, all right.
So, I'm going ingest into
this space of preservation all
of the description of hardware,
all of the operating system,
all the executable libraries,
all of the application.
Plus, the actual object that's
being interpreted and incorporate
that into a great big bundle
and run it as a virtual,
in a virtual machine environment.
And in his first work he did
this on laptop, that was capable
of emulating other hardware.
But he had an idea that this is so,
these virtual machines are so big,
that he ought to find
some alternative way
of running the software and
then having to draw it all
into one box all at once.
So, he got this idea about
using this streaming video,
which all of us see on YouTube and
other applications as a metaphor
for pulling only that
which is needed
from this gigantic virtual machine
into the executing environment.
And so, it's sort of like a paging
system in a time-shared machine.
So, it's actually not
too easy though.
In the case of streaming video,
it's pretty well ordered.
You just pull in the next frame.
And if you want to get a
little ahead of the game,
you pull in a few more
frames ahead of time so that
if there's some stuttering in the
network you don't see a flicker
in the video or a stutter
in the audio.
But in the case of a virtual machine
execution, if you're taking pages
of software in, the
program jumps around.
And so, the pages that are
needed are not necessarily just
in simple sequential order.
So, you have to be pretty
clever about drawing in pieces
of the virtual machine as
needed in order to execute that.
So, he basically uses demand
paging, which is to say
if you're executing a piece of code
and it needs to get to another part
of the executable program, you just
pull the page in when it's needed,
but then you try to watch what the
patterns are and you pre-fetch pages
to avoid delay in order
to make this work.
So, I know that you don't want
to dive, I assume you don't want
to dive too deep into all this.
So, I'm not going to talk
about every single layer
in this architecture,
except to say that it's
like any other conventional machine,
except you run a virtual
machine kernel
so that it can emulate
the hardware of machines
that are no longer available,
and then you run the operating
system inside of that environment
and then run the application so
the virtual machine image has all
of this stuff that's needed
and it's expressed in XML
so this looks like
a web application.
So, you can imagine simply
running on a computer connected
to the internet something that looks
like it's connected to a server
on the Worldwide Web and
it's pulling in XML pages,
but in fact what it's doing is
running this virtual machine.
So, this is sort of an
image of what it looks like.
He's using the QEMU, QEMU
KVM kernel virtual machine.
And then, for example, he
was running Microsoft Windows
and he was running an
app on top of that.
He has a cache which
is the clean cache,
which hasn't experienced
any execution.
And then as the program runs, he
has to keep track of what's changed.
And he goes out and pulls stuff in.
So, the way this tends to work
is that you can even run this
in such a way that the
virtual machine is not even
on your desktop or laptop.
It's actually running in the cloud.
And the only thing that you
present to the client is the image.
Some of you may even remember
something called X Windows
that was developed at MIT, which
had a similar kind of notion,
you just displayed the bits that
were appropriate on the screen.
And all the other execution,
including the generation
of the display was done
back in the server.
So, we can certainly
consider doing that as well,
in order to limit was is
needed on the client side.
So, we still have a long way
before we're done with all of this.
For one thing, actually handling
this increasingly large virtual
machine structure is not so
easy, and yet we are expanding,
those of us who build cloud systems,
Google and Microsoft, and IBM,
and elsewhere, Amazon, are building
larger, and larger capacity systems
with multicore processors
and more and more memory.
But the hardest part seems to be
getting precession in the emulation
of the hardware, including mistakes
that have been made I the hardware
that the application
actually relied on,
even though it was a bug
in the hardware design.
And so, getting that
accurately is tricky.
And not all machine designers
are necessarily willing to hand
out to you the details of
their hardware instruction set.
And so, here's another example of
a kind of exception one would look
for for preservation purposes.
I think just I won't go through this
list completely but the idea here is
for us to recognize that
we're going to need expertise
in the hardware space and
the operating system space.
And if we're going to make
this a general-purpose notion,
we have to ask ourselves will people
who write operating
systems be willing
to part with the source code?
Will they be willing to make
available executable object code?
Will they be willing to
do this on a regular basis
for purposes of preservation?
Will they allow execution
of the emulated hardware
and the emulated operating
system for thousands of people
and not necessarily
get paid for that.
At some point the patents
expire, the other rights expire
and the general public needs to
have access to these executables
if they're going to be able to
reference material which doesn't run
in any other environment.
This should be of personal concern
to those of you who produce content.
Because if you experience, like I
have material produced 20 years ago,
that no longer is accessible.
I have PowerPoint slides from 1997
that don't run on today's
PowerPoint.
And this is not a gratuitous dig at
Microsoft, I'm not expecting them
to be able to run backward
compatibility for 20 years.
But it's really a shock
when you pull up something
that you worked hard on and realize
that it's not available anymore.
And its content has been lost.
And so, I actually kept an old IBM
ThinkPad around running Windows XP
and an old version of
Microsoft, that just happens
to reach far enough back
to pick up those pages,
but I've had to reproduce the pages.
So, I want to turn now, so
this is one part of the story.
And it's using virtual
machine technology in order
to preserve executability
over a long period of time.
But I want to turn now to
the self-archiving web idea.
This notion was first introduced
to me last year by Tim Berners-Lee
and David Reid and Brewster Kahle.
And their idea was that the
web is this femoral thing.
We all realize that the web
is what it is in the instant.
It doesn't automatically
archive itself,
it doesn't remember previous pages.
And so, all we see when we
go online is today's web.
We don't see yesterday's
web or yester year's web.
And that's a pity.
Because seeing things over a period
of time can often be
extremely illuminating.
I've been told more than once that
content that might be very important
to understanding our
history may not appear
to be important for
quite a long time.
A hundred years, two hundred years.
Until finally we realize looking
back, this document, that decisions,
this website marked an
important moment in our history,
but we didn't know that at the time
because we didn't have
enough perspective.
And so, preservation of this
content is really important.
So, I've been thinking
a lot about this.
And I think the success
of the internet might teach
us a few lessons about how
to approach a self-archiving
web design.
One of them is that collaboration
and cooperation were essential
to the internet's evolution.
Bob Kahn and I may
have started all this.
But believe me it took millions
of people and still does
to keep the network going, and
growing, and changing, and evolving.
And the atmosphere around
its creation invited that.
It's a very open design.
Anyone with an idea was free
to express that idea and try
to persuade others that they
should adopt those ideas.
And in the internet
engineering task force
where the standards are
made, that process continues.
Arguments are based on merit
not based on anything else.
And if your ideas are
accepted they get implemented.
And if they aren't they don't.
But the other thing
that was important is
that we published the design
openly, without any restrictions,
which is kind of amazing when you
consider this was done in 1973
in the middle of the Cold War.
And we just published the details of
the architecture and the protocols.
People have asked us how did
you get permission to do that?
And the answer is,
well we didn't ask.
But we had a rationale for it.
We said, okay we want
this to be available
to the American Defense
Department so they don't have
to buy a particular brand of
machine in order to network them.
Because back then we had SNA for
IBM, we had DECnet for digital.
But we didn't think the Defense
Department should be forced
into buying only one brand
of machine to have network.
So, we said let's do a
nonproprietary design.
And then we said, our allies will
probably need access to this too,
because we'll want them to be
able to interwork in a command
and control system built on top.
Then we said, well okay,
so who are our allies?
And well, we could answer
that question in 1973.
But we said, well who will
they be 25 years from now?
And we weren't sure.
We looked back 25 years and
realized that the allies of today,
that is '73, were different from
the ones, you know 25 years ago.
So, we assumed that we would not
know who our allies were 25 years
from now and since
this needed to work,
we said everybody has
to be able to do it.
So, we just published openly
and said, if you can build stuff
that works this way
and find somebody
to connect to, it should work.
And so, the internet grew in
a very organic way precisely
for that reason.
We also said, we didn't care
what the business model was.
And so, we said just,
it has to work this way,
but we don't care what
your business model is.
So, we have nonprofit networks
and we have for profit networks,
government operated
networks, private networks
like the ones you run at home with
your Wi-Fi service that connect
into the rest of the internet.
We were also very conscious of
hiding information among the layers
of the architecture,
so that the IT packets
or the internet protocol
packets didn't have
to know how they were being carried.
So, new technology could be swept
in without changing that protocol.
We also said that the little
internet package should be
pretty stupid.
They don't know what
they're carrying.
All they know is they're
carrying bits.
They don't know what the bits mean.
And that was good because if
you added a new application,
all you had to do was reinterpret
the bits at the edges of the net.
You didn't have to
change the network,
because the network didn't
know and it didn't care.
And so, this kind of modularity
and information hiding
has been vastly helpful
in allowing new applications
to be built on the network.
And so of course out of many
one that is the internet.
So, I gave a version of this
talk out at the Internet Archive,
Brewster Kahle's operation,
which you should visit
because it's an old
Christian Science Church,
and he even has the
pews are still there.
And in the back, he has
all the petabytes of memory
that are stored away
with the flashing lights.
And he has a whole
bunch of mannequins
that are sitting on the pews.
He moved them off to the right and
left so that we had our meeting,
you know live people could
be sitting in the pews.
I only accepted questions
from the mannequins
on the left and the right.
Safety measure.
So, I've been thinking a
little bit about what kinds
of technology we have to
incorporate into our thinking
for our digital preservation.
Compression schemes, in
order to use the, you know,
lease amount of space, tarball
thing like that, which are common.
And we need to store and
recover, up until now,
this notion of compression
and everything else involves
particular objects that get stored
and then fully recovered.
But the Worldwide Web is
a much more complex thing,
because it's got pages
that point to other pages.
It's a complex, it's a web.
And so, figuring out how to
retain that part in addition
to the particular objects
is important.
So just preserving the webpage with
this HTML without the ability to go
where the links went, or to
go to a place that replicates
where the links went, means what we
have a very static representation
of the net, we don't
understand its connectivity.
And we obviously have to think about
webpages that change over time.
So, how do we keep track of
which versions we're looking at?
The programmers do this all the
time with programmers' workbench
and things of that sorts.
So, this Worldwide Web is a
really complex reference structure
so we have to deal with that.
So, Brewster, Brewster Kahle has
been running the Internet Archive
for at least 15 years,
maybe more, 20?
And it's taking snapshots of the
Worldwide Web and storing them away.
It's indexed in time.
So, he has a way back machine that
lets you see what the web looked
like at a certain year,
or a certain month.
He also has to do something
with the hyperlinks.
Because it's pretty clear
that if you just copy the page
and its hyperlinks, 10 years from
now, or maybe even tomorrow clicking
on the link might fail because the
destination isn't available anymore.
So, he has to convert the hyperlinks
into something that he can point
to inside the space of
his internet archive.
So, he has to essentially
virtualize all of that.
So, it's a self-contained system.
And he has to be crawling the
web constantly, just like we do
at Google to create the index.
And then there's this
question of when is a page new?
And you certainly wouldn't
want pages
to be snapshot every time
you change one character.
So, we have to have some kind of a
notion about publishing of a page,
saying I know what this page
version to be seen by everybody.
So, that's an instant in time
that should mark when you want
to capture the web, that webpage.
And then I keep thinking about
trying to capture everything that's
on the web, and I thought about that
philosophical problem do the set
of all sets contain itself,
and I decided not to think
about that anymore, because
it gave me a headache.
So, I'm sorry you might
want to get a cup of coffee.
So, I worry also about the
amount of space required
to retain the evolving
web, it's history,
because it can barely
contain itself as it is.
I mean there's you know
all this space is taken
up by all these webpages.
And so, there's this idea of
lots of copies keep things safe,
but I'm kind of worried about how
much storage we actually can afford
to retain over long periods of time.
So, we have to be thoughtful
about that.
I'll come back to digital
object identifiers
when I give me Vint Cerf
version of outcomes talk.
And then there is this
other question about HTML,
which itself has been evolving,
it's gone from the original HTML
to various versions, to
XML, to HTML 5 and so on.
It's going to keep changing too.
And so, whatever we do in terms of
archiving is going to have to take
that into account because the
HTML of the webpage is just going
to change over time and our ability
to interpret that is going to have
to keep up with that evolutions,
and then I relay it back
to permissions and access control.
Some contents may be
access controlled now
for copyright reasons,
or for monetary reasons.
And yet 100 years from now those
constraints may no longer be valid
and we have to understand
when it's going
to be okay to make access open.
And so, this creates a
fairly complex environment,
where we literally have to keep
track of the access controls
and rights of every one of the
objects pointed to in the archive.
So, I keep thinking about how
to make this more automatic.
And one possibility is that
while you're creating webpages,
and launching them by saying I want
to publish, is that the environment
that we use to say, oh and by
the way this page now needs
to be archived.
And can we make that kind of a
standard and cooperative practice?
I keep thinking about Google Docs
and one of the interesting things
about Google Docs is
that we replicate these
across our multiple data centers
to keep from losing anything.
We actually also allow multiple
parties to edit these documents
at the same time, which
is absolutely amazing.
We don't get confused
and lose things.
But the idea of replicating
over multiple storage environments
is going to have to be part
of this archival process as well.
Then, we have this problem of making
references to the various objects.
And so, the web archiving
entities whoever they are may need
to have some common reference space
so that each of them can ingest
and correctly regurgitate
pages on demand.
So, if they don't have a
common reference frame,
reference terminology, and
reference space, that won't work.
And so, I keep thinking,
that Google,
you know does this sharding
thing where we take objects
and we break them all up and
spread them across multiple sites
in the Google Drive and I'm
hoping that I can convince some
of the Google executives that we
should be a party to this as well.
So, here's some more
thinking out loud.
Some of you will be
familiar with publish
and subscribe protocol regimes.
And this feels to me like
it might be a place where,
that notion could be used as
part of the archiving process.
You know I declare this
webpage now archivable.
And so please publish that fact
to the archiving community.
Some of them may ingest
the pages, some may not.
They may choose to ingest pages of
certain type or certain content.
We want that to be flexible so
that we don't force every archive
to archive everything, but
we want it to be rich enough
that we can archive almost
everything over the sum of all
of the archiving processes.
Plainly, we need a lot of
metadata and so we'll have
to have a way to express that.
We'll have to have agreements
about how that gets captured
and how it gets interpreted.
And then there's this rending
of the digital objects.
And whether it's just presenting
them or interacting with them,
we have to have all the software
that's needed in order to do that.
And that has to be preserved
over a period of time again,
and back to the virtual
machine notion.
And then there's this
permission to use question.
How do we represent that?
How do we validate parties
who are accessing the content?
At which point can we say the
content is no longer controlled
and protected because its
copyrights have expired
or other rights are no longer valid?
So, if we're trying to surf the
self-archiving web, one question is
which of the archives do we go
to when we make a page reference.
And figuring out how to resolve
to multiple targets is
another part of this problem.
Because there should
be multiple targets.
If I go to a particular webpage that
I'm trying to get to, I should have,
the resolution system should
give me different choices
because there should be multiple
places where I can go to get
that content, otherwise
we're back at risk
that that one place goes away.
This, you know how newspapers, and
magazines and books are snapshots
of a particular work in time.
We have editions of newspapers;
we have editions of magazines.
I kind of wonder at what rate
we should be snapshotting the
Worldwide Web.
And I don't know the answer to that.
Probably part of it is the rate
at which things are changing
determine how often we
should snapshot.
But I'd really rather have a clue
that something is worth
snapshotting,
as opposed to simply
taking a million pictures
and hoping some of
them are appropriate.
So, what else?
Well, properties that would be
attractive, automatic archiving
when you declare that
you're publishing.
Is it a service that
you sign up for?
How is that funded?
What about registering
the software that's needed
to interpret the webpages, and a
permission system that goes with it.
And now what do we do about stuff
that turns out to be malware?
Do we want to archive that and
if we do, if we archive it,
do we have a way to mark it so that
if you're going in the archive,
you don't accidentally ingest
a serious virus or something
because you were out there
in the digital stacks?
So, we may want that, you
know for history purposes
to understand what the threats
were in this online environment,
but we also have to protect people.
So, we have to recognize
what we're going.
And then there's this
fidelity of the experience
in the online environment.
You know, one thing is just
to look at the webpage itself
without actually being able
to execute any of the links.
But something deeper
than that is the ability
to actually exercise the webpage
as it would have been
when it was running.
So, what happens once
a page is archived?
Do we make sure that it's indelible?
Do we do digital signatures on it to
make sure that it can't be changed?
That might turn out to be important
because in a court case you
don't want somebody to say,
my webpage had the following
things on it in 1997, or 2005.
But you can change it in order to,
you know modify the
court's decisions.
You don't want that to happen
if you're going to attribute
to the storage system
legal validity.
What about if we make the
self-archiving web work,
will some of the records be
considered official records
like the ones that go
into the National Archive?
What happens if the
content's encrypted?
So, now we have some problem
because we can't see it
unless we have the keys,
but where do we store the keys?
And who's responsible for
key management, and you know,
anybody who's ever
forgotten their password,
will appreciate how
hard it is to keep keys
around for decrypting content.
And then there's this
access control question
that keeps coming up all the time.
So, some of you will have some
familiarity with the notion
of containers that's
starting to come along
in online cloud environment.
Containers are actually kind of
interesting because they are a way
of boxing together everything you
need in order to execute something.
So, this is very much like
the digital realm environment
that I imagine.
And so, it could be that we have
in our hands some technology
that will help us do this automatic
archiving and rendering of the web
over time because the
container has everything
in it that we need to do that.
There are some other projects
that you all know about
and we've already mentioned
some of them anyway,
that the internet archive
being obvious.
The Library of Alexandria
in Alexandria Egypt is one
of the backup sites for
the internet archive.
And I think there's something
delicious about that.
It seems very appropriate.
Ismail Serageldin is
the librarian there.
Soon to retire he says.
A big lose in my view.
But it's important
that whatever we do
that we have multiple
archives for this content.
The Computer History Museum has
been saving the software as well
as computing artifacts, software is
being saved in the internet archive.
Google has been scanning books
and the cultural institute has
been capturing images from many,
many museums around the world.
And then finally, there's the
digital object architecture
that Bob Kahn's worked on.
And with permission, I'd like
to give you a brief rendering
of that process, because I believe
it can play a very important role
in the implementation of
the self-archiving web.
So, in order to do that, I need
to go pick up these slides.
Now, I should warn you that this
is me trying to channel Bob Kahn.
And so, I'm not sure that I will do
this beautifully, but I will try.
So, the first thing is that this
digital object architecture uses the
term handle system.
Its handles are kind
of like domain names.
They're references
to digital objects.
And once you have this handle, when
you resolve it, it takes you to,
or points you to that
digital object.
So, the handle is a permanent thing.
That's a sign, it doesn't
get changed.
Never gets reassigned
to anything else.
And in theory doesn't disappear.
This stuff is in use.
So, I am not speculating at
this point, I am telling you
about something which is
actually functioning and in use
and you can see a list here,
which I won't read to you.
So, the important part
here is that stuff
that works is really important.
I mean it's sort of
like the internet.
Things that work persist.
And I'm hoping that the
handle system will have
that property as well.
So, there's pieces
in this architecture.
There's the client that's
trying to get access
to an object by way of a handle.
There is discovering what
resources are available
down in the lower left.
You know where can I go?
In order to get things.
Where, how do I find something?
So, I need a resolution system
in the lower right for you.
And then finally, you
want to go to a place
where the objects are located.
And so, this very simple,
conceptual architecture made
up of these four components.
So, here's an object.
It's in the architecture.
The digital object is
in the architecture
as a first-class citizen
in the internet.
So, the notion of digital object
becomes a first-class concept.
So, we want to be able to
take these objects as objects,
move them around, store
them away, recover them,
interpret them, and so on.
These things could be quite complex.
They can have all different
kinds of content in them.
Could be video, could be
audio, could be a mix of that.
Could be executables.
Virtually anything you
can digitize should be,
you know implementable
as a digital object.
And the whole idea behind the handle
system is that it helps you find
where is it and what am
I allowed to do with it.
So, here's the digital object.
It has information in it.
It has the type of content.
It has the unique identifier
and it responds to requests
to render itself, for example,
or to deliver some content
and it gets distributed.
So, here's an example, here's
"Hamlet" which is a work.
And it's got data elements in it.
It's got content types.
And they're all interconnected
with each other.
They could be rendered as print,
they could be rendered as,
well I guess Bob intended, scrolls?
I don't know, can you imagine
reading "Hamlet" on a scroll?
Okay. Doing somebody
else's slides is sort
of like delving into
their psychology.
That's why I never let
anybody read my code,
right because they can tell
everything about my head
by looking at how I write software.
So, we have this unique identifier,
they reference sequences
of typed bytes.
So, there's types associated with
the digital content of the objects.
And it might have more
than one content type.
So, there's an identifier.
An identifier has a
bunch of content in it.
The handle service helps us find
it in a repository somewhere.
And that's basically
all there is to it.
Well, there's more.
This is theorem number 206,
which reads everything
is more complicated.
And the closer you look at anything,
the more complicated it gets.
So, this is sort of the full
rendering of the handle service,
which is helping you
find the objects,
and maybe even search by type.
You know you might only want to
look for video, you might only want
to look for print material
and so on.
So, here's the kind of, that's
probably not even readable it's
so small, but the idea here is
to take that webpage for example
and capture all of
its data and metadata
and store it away as
a digital object.
So, when the publisher produces
content, it gets stored away.
Oh, it is presented
to the collection service
along with its metadata.
Handle data is generated and
stored away in the handle system
so you can find it again.
Metadata gets stored away elsewhere
and the handle system can
help you find it after that.
So, a repository is where
you store this stuff.
It provides for dynamic
acquisitions and things can come
into the repository and
an execution capability.
So, the code that implements
the different kinds
of content rendering can be
executed in that environment.
And it has an access protocol
called repository access
protocol surprisingly.
And that's a standard.
And so, this allows multiple
repositories to be created
and to be part of the environment.
So, there's the client rapping
with the repository so to speak.
So, the handle system
itself is distributed.
So, this is the thing that takes
the handle resolves it and tells you
where to go and what to do.
And there are a variety of
different transformations.
A handle could turn into a domain
name for example, or it could turn
into something that points
directly into a repository.
It's all well-define and so, the
client goes to the handle services,
there's a global handle
resolution system
and local handle resolution system.
So, you can have handles
resolve locally.
And if they don't know what
to do locally then they go
to the global handle
resolution systems in order
to get further data, it's a
little bit like the root system
in the domain name environment.
So, you can see these
things distributed.
Local handle resolution
system can also be replicated
in multiple sites.
And finally, you know
we get actual objects
that are part of that system.
So, here's an example of a
handle might contain information
in that's of URL type.
And the data is familiar
URL, but there are lots
of other possibilities here.
One of them might be the digital
library system type of data
which has a reference which is
different from domain names or URLs.
Our handle system administration
system.
So, you have a variety
of possibilities here,
including extensions.
So, it could be x, y, z handle type.
And it has a certain
binary representation,
and it gets interpreted on a
basis of what that handle type is.
So, some libraries that actually
implement this stuff will be
reachable through the web
for example, or more directly
from digital library services using
the repository access protocol.
So, the library could be first-class
object in this repository system,
or it might be reached through the
Worldwide Web, through a webserver,
which knows how to
talk to a repository.
And then the repository
responds with content.
And that actually was the
last slide believe it or not.
So, I'm happy to just stop here.
I realize that I may have
even overstayed my welcome,
because it's after 10 o'clock.
What does one mean?
I can have one question?
No.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Oh, okay well I'll tell you
what if you have questions,
I will do my best to answer them.
Do we have roving microphones,
or do I run around?
Okay. So, let me warn you that
I'm hearing impaired and what
that means, I'm not the guy that
came to talk and wouldn't listen,
that's not my problem [laugther].
But I may have to run around
to lipread if necessary.
So, let's try and if I'm having
trouble hearing the question I may
leap off the stage,
in which case the guys
who are videotaping this will have a
great time trying to figure out how
to find me hiding behind
the columns here
in this perfectly structured
room for lectures.
Okay. So, are there?
There's a question over here, but
the microphone is over that way.
So, we'll get you.
You're number 2, just
remember your number.
First question.
>> SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
That was very interesting.
I was going to ask about
portable data in the role of that.
I mean right now you can't dump
everything you've ever posted
on Facebook, or like all your
emails from Gmail into a folder,
or perhaps transfer
to another service.
>> VINT CERF: Wait, wait let's stop.
Because I'm getting
about 40% of this.
Hold on. I'm sorry.
Yeah, yeah go ahead.
>> SPEAKER 1: Portable data,
what's the word of portable data
and basically transferring your
data from one service to another
and backing it up on hard drive.
[ Laughter ]
>> VINT CERF: Somehow this isn't
working the way I was expecting it
to work.
Okay, this is part
of my health plan.
I think everybody understands that.
So, you know storing all
of the data that you have,
first of all we don't have
common standards across all
of those various services,
which is a pity.
I mean, I think we should.
But we don't.
And so, pulling all that stuff
into your own hard drive
gives you the problem
that you don't have
enough room to store it.
So, this leaves you with
a couple of possibilities.
One is you ingest all these stuff.
And then you push it in
opaque form into some,
you know cloud based storage
system, whether it's you know AWS,
or Google, or something else.
That has to be the
worst possible outcome.
Because it's not structured.
It's not properly curated.
It's just there in an opaque form.
And only you can retrieve it.
That might be great for privacy,
but it's not a good thing
for historical purposes.
And so, now we could
argue whether all
that stuff is worth saving or not.
And some people will say,
it isn't worth saving
and so stop worry about it.
But I would argue two things; one,
if you think it's important to save,
you should have mechanisms
for saving it
in a way that's useful,
possibly for historians.
And second observation, again is
that we don't always know
what's important and what isn't.
So, again though I think if
you're the creator of content
in a sense you should
have the choice
of whether it gets saved or not.
Once you publish it though in
an environment which is open,
which is true of much of the web
today, and I hope it stays that way,
you've sort of committed yourself to
history whether you like it or not.
And I think that has
to be thought about.
Once we demonstrate the
capability to archive this,
people who produce content
should be well aware
that it might be archived.
And maybe that will cause
people to think twice
about what they put up on the net.
Okay. We have time for one more?
Do you think?
Okay, this gentleman over here,
no actually the guy behind you.
Yeah, I'm sorry he was number two.
He had his hand up first.
I'll take a third question
whether Wendy wants me to or not.
Yes? Okay, go ahead.
>> SPEAKER 2: Thank you very much.
So, you made a really, really
nice point is that we need;
I'll wait for him to
do the mic [laughter].
So, we need multiple.
I just have a one to one.
>> VINT CERF: I need a microphone.
>> SPEAKER 3: All right
here's another microphone.
>> SPEAKER 2: Okay so, we need
multiple, like you said, archives.
And that's the kind
of future potentially.
We're going to be doing it.
Everyone's going to be archiving.
But what's the kind of mech?
Do you perceive a mechanism to
emerge from these multiple archives
to allow the kind of distributive
approach to discover them?
Is this something that
is going to be organic?
Or is this something that is
going to be a top down kind
of layer that's going to
be enforced by someone.
>> VINT CERF: It would be.
I guess I can do it
this way now, okay.
Except I'm hiding from the camera.
Okay, all right [laughter].
So, first of all, it
would be a pity if we were
to rely on some top down thing.
It works so much better when you
have an architecture and a set
of protocols and design that
allows people who wish to commit
to this, to be able to do so.
And so, I'm must more interested
in getting the technology
into people's hands, maybe build
in as part of the web environment.
That's why this self-archiving
web notion is so appealing to me.
You don't think about it, it just
archives itself automatically.
But you need to say
whether you are turning on
or turning off the
archiving mechanism.
Business models are going
to be really important here.
I have an acquaintance who is
starting a company called emortal
and it's all about trying
to preserve digital content
for families in the future.
And he was trying to figure
out a business model for this.
And he came up with a
very interesting idea.
You all know about
life insurance, right?
You know how this works,
you pay until you're dead.
I don't know of any other
product that has that property,
maybe some of the drug
companies have that.
So, what if you had a kind
of data life insurance thing,
where you pay to save your
data over a period of time
and you accumulate what
is needed in order to,
what's the right word for this?
Endow the archival process.
So, that it can be paid
for over a period of time.
Now, I have no idea if that idea
is actually going to work or not.
But, this notion of providing a
business model is pretty important.
Again, I don't think we want to
save information by accident.
We want to have mechanisms that are
self-supporting over the long term.
Okay, maybe one more and that's it.
Yeah? Okay.
Okay go for it.
>> SPEAKER 4: So, you talked a lot
about technologies of preservation
and yet, they would really depend
on kind of a social infrastructure
to organizations, institutions
that care about preservation.
You have a few of them here,
the Library of Congress,
the British Library.
And yet there's too thin on the
ground perhaps for us to do the job.
And it seems to me that on the whole
society cares about preservation
after we've lost something.
Instead we ought to prevent it.
And I just wonder where
that conundrum comes,
because where we have a prime
institution that attempts
to resurrect information to
preserve it, I take example
of the Google Books for
example, then other stakeholders
who see value, potentially,
start to fight back
against the preservation of it.
So how do we address this
conundrum, that we care,
but not care enough to [inaudible].
>> VINT CERF: So, in fact
the answer may very well be
that we don't do that.
Let me explain.
Let's imagine for the
sake of argument,
that the Worldwide Web becomes
a self-archiving system.
What is the implication of that?
The implication is that the
same parties that provide you
with the method for producing
your, you know Twitter pages
and your blogs and all these
other things are also engaged
in the archiving process.
You know think for a minute,
they have a business model,
that whether it's advertising,
or you pay, or something else.
And so, the question is whether
we could induce into the system,
the archiving process as the
normal part of the way it works,
as opposed to separating it
as an act that's distinct.
And you know the more
we keep thinking
about it's an act that's distinct,
the harder we make the problem.
But if we incorporate this
into the normal process
and replication becomes part of the
normal process, we may actually end
up with a self-archiving environment
that works and is supported.
Because there's already a
business model for the generation
of the data, why not incorporate
into that this preservation as well.
Now, I just said something
that might be really hard
to implement, but it's not crazy.
Because if you think about it,
none of the things that are
on the web today were there before
until somebody decided they wanted
to make a business of doing it.
And so, let's see if we can't
build preservation into the norm,
as opposed to making it a special
action of only a few parties.
End of story.
Okay.
[ Applause ]
>> DAME WENDY HALL: I wanted to say,
I wanted to lead the applause here.
But, before we let Vint go, we're
going to have a coffee break now.
We'll be back here at 10:45 to
start the panels and presentations.
And there is, if you're standing at
the back, there's a room downstairs
with the webcast going with seats.
So, feel free to use
that if you want to.
I just want to say a
big thank you to Vint
for making the effort
to come here today.
And as ever, I'm blown over
by some of the things he says.
He, I mean I think I'm
immersed in this world.
And he just has so much insight.
Digital vellum is now
my favorite phrase,
you haven't trademarked
it, have you?
No.
>> VINT CERF: No.
>> DAME WENDY HALL: And I'm
not going to, it's all right.
It's just and also the idea
of the self-archiving web.
I think this is an amazing
way of capturing everything
that we're trying to talk about.
And the fact that Vint is still
coming up with all these new ideas
that leave the rest of us
just completely gob smacked is
quite amazing.
So, let's once more thank Vint
very much for just being Vint.
[ Applause ]
>> VINT CERF: Thank you.
>> DAME WENDY HALL: Now is the
time to hear about what happened
at the hack-a-thon, or I like
to called them datathons.
Doesn't really matter.
Well they're now forever called
Archives Unleased in this context.
And we had a wonderful two
days with people from all
over the world actually who
came to work with the data.
I'm not going to tell you about it.
I'm going to introduce you
to the team who run it.
You've got their bios in the
pack to Ian Milligan, Jimmy Lin
and Matt Weber, my
co-host for today as well.
So, Ian I think you're first up.
Ian, over to you.
Round of applause for Ian.
[ Applause ]
>> IAN MILLIGAN: I'll just start by,
could we get our four other speakers
up, we'll just make them sit
in these bright lights at the
front of the stage [laughter].
And that way we can
be a bit quicker.
I think we'll need
Dan as well up here.
Hi. My name is Ian Milligan, I'm
an assistant professor of history
at the University of Waterloo.
And Jimmy, Matt, myself, and a few
other organizers, I'll show you,
just spent the last few
days running a datathon here
at the Library of Congress.
The first question I want to do,
before we get into the nitty gritty
is just rhetorically talk a little
bit about why I think these
sorts of events are important.
And the question I like to ask
is why is a historian helping
to organize a datathon
around web archives.
And I think it's because in short,
as we've heard earlier today
from Vint and we'll
be hearing today,
we have a problem facing our
collective cultural heritage.
This is a big issue that
we need to be involved in.
And when I go on talks and
try to sum it up to audiences,
I like to encapsulate the problem
and the opportunity facing us
in something as innocuous as
this, a page from GeoCities.com.
GeoCities.com, founded
in 1994, deleted in 2009;
saved thanks to web archivists, was
the kind of place where you could go
and create your own website about
anything that you so desire.
You'd go to GeoCities.com,
type in your email address,
get your free megabyte,
two megabytes,
eventually ten megabytes of content.
Whippy. And it was a big deal.
And you could create a site
about anything that you wanted.
You could create your love site
to "Buffy the Vampire Slayer,"
your lamentation about the Toronto
Maple Leaf, your family tree,
your love of Winnie the Pooh
if you're a 12-year-old child.
And people took that to an extreme.
And people jumped on
board with such aplomb.
And I love this visualization
because it shows just how quickly
people took to creating content
and leaving it behind
on the Worldwide Web.
GeoCities.com had its first
10,000 users in October of 1995,
100,000 in August of 1996.
A million in October 1997.
And by its deletion in 2009,
some 7 million people had
created webpages on GeoCities.com.
And when today we want to go
through and see how many URL exist,
it's something like
186 million URLs.
GeoCities.com, a tiny slice
of the web of the nineties
and the two thousands accounts
for this much information.
And as a historian,
that fascinates me.
It boggles the mind.
It means that we are
operating on a different scale
of the preservation
of everyday people.
The example I like to make
just to bug my colleagues
who do British history mostly,
is to say let's take your golden,
you know your treasure trove
of historical information,
if you want to study the 19th
century or the 18th century
and see what it was like to be
an everyday person say in London,
you have almost no information.
You only have information
when people come into contact
with the state, or the church,
or if an accident happens
and something is left behind.
And so, for many historians, they
reconstruct that sort of life
through court transcripts,
like the "Old Bailey Online"
which between 1674 and 1913
collected 197,000 trials.
They just, the describe their site
as quote, unquote, "the largest body
of sources ever created
by nonelite people."
And that's true until
something like GeoCities.
In short, historians are
moving from scarcity,
where we used to have no
information about the past,
to abundance where we have too much.
That I like to present this as the
problem with the "Old Bailey" was
that you always wished you had
more information and the problem
with GeoCities is that
you wish you had less.
And so, that's why we
do these datathons.
Our animating statement is
that web archives are great,
they present a tremendous
opportunity just,
it makes my skin chilled when
I think about them, but access
and usage of web archived content
remains a very considerable problem.
And so, we bring people
together to run these datathons.
Over the last few days we brought
together and introduced plenary team
to bring together international
participants here.
And it's a team of a historian,
a communications study scholar,
Natalie who you'll
hear from shortly.
A computer scientist, Jimmy
who's in this room, Matt Weber,
who you'll be hearing from this
afternoon, and Nicholas Worby,
a librarian who, selfishly
is getting married tomorrow
and had to go back to Toronto.
But we'll send him our
congratulations from afar.
What did we aim to accomplish
over the last three days?
Well, we wanted to build community.
Community of people who
could use web archives
to answer interesting questions
about the past and today.
We wanted to articulate
a common vision
of web archiving development
and tool development.
We wanted to avoid the black
boxes of search engines
that we don't understand.
We don't want to design search
engines where I type in a keyword,
and it goes through billions
of files and gives me 10
and I don't know why I got those 10.
And most importantly we want
to equip us as a collective,
and that's the people
in the room datathoning,
and also I think our society.
To deal and work with born
digital, cultural resources.
So, datathons are tricky.
And we call them datathons, it's
a bit less scary than hack-a-thon.
But, we really try to bring
together diverse perspectives.
We try to bring together
people who can hack,
who have the technical chops to
write code, make dreams a reality,
but also those with
theoretical ideas.
They want to talk,
have conversations,
think about the ethics,
the standards, etcetera.
And so, a datathon really tries
to balance the perspectives
of humanists, like myself,
and computer scientists,
and social scientists
who are also in the room.
What did we do, in a
very quick nutshell?
Well, on Monday, it's hard
to believe that was Monday,
we gathered at George Washington
University Library to form teams.
A great Sticky Note
exercise thinking
about datasets people wanted to
use, questions they might have.
We framed the problem,
we socialized.
We do a lot of socializing if
you come to our hackathons.
Then, in this room on
Tuesday at the Library
of Congress we had
quick presentations,
we solidified our teams, and
really we just started datathoning.
It was just a buzz of
activity as people worked away.
We had incredible catering.
If you want to run an event, this is
a plug for the Library of Congress,
the are the best event staff ever.
You've got like a bucket
of M&M's here.
I don't know if that's
healthy, but it was good.
Mostly it was just quiet work.
Hacking, data flowing,
and some awesome results
that I'm really happy to be able to
share with you in a just a minute.
And then of course, today
we're here wrapping it all up.
The projects, we had
basically eight major projects,
which I'll talk about.
We didn't have time to bring
all eight teams up here
to share their results,
unfortunately due to
time constraints.
So, I'm going to talk about four and
then we have these four pour people
in the hot seats who are
going to share their projects
with very strict three-minute
time limits.
But I have the pleasure to talk
about a few quick projects.
So, one team here looked at Twitter
and they took a large data dump
of Twitter and asked, what is
the source of the narratives
in election related Tweets.
And so, here we're seeing they
took 327,000 Tweets hashtag
with election 2016.
The real Donald Trump of Hillary
Clinton account, 7,000 URLs.
And we can see topics relating
to the Russian DNC hack,
the Trump revoking "The
Washington Post" credentials,
and the case of Omar Mateen's
wife after the Orlando shooting.
And we're just seeing those
surges of activities over time.
The team took the IMLS museum
datasets, this monumental sort
of terabytes or terabytes of
American museums and tried to figure
out what you could do with
[inaudible] files that drive it,
the CDX files that give
context to web archives.
And it was amazing.
I mean here we're seeing a domain
map of the American museum space,
and we also saw interesting
things looking
at which different file formats
speak to different types of content.
There was a team called the
Supremes, it was a great name.
And they used the Library of
Congress web archiving collection.
They used websites collected
around the nomination of Alito,
and the nomination
of Justice Roberts.
Took those websites and did things
like extracted the links and seeing
which websites link
to other websites.
Who do discussions
on the senate link
to where do discussions
on the house link to.
And also, did quite a bit of
content analysis taking the text
and visualizing in new ways.
Their take-home they wanted me
to emphasize was know your data.
What are your assumptions?
They generated this great graph,
it shows yea, that's about Roberts.
I told them to lie, that's
a great visualization
because he was confirmed, and
they tell me it was actually,
they were scraping in the
Library of congress tons and tons
of yeas and nays roll calls.
So, their message was you
have to know your data.
And then finally there was
a team Campaign Origins,
the research question,
where do the topics
in election-related Twitter
conversations originate?
And they grabbed, they
topic modelled
in this case Donald Trump's
information and we saw
that it was his birthday
a few days ago.
And, those were our
quick little teams.
I might be missing one.
And then, I'm just going
to turn us over here
to our four lightening talks.
So, we have them in
order, Team Mojitos,
Team I Know What You Hid
Last Summer, Team Turtle,
and then Team Counter Terrorism.
So, we'll go in that order.
And I'll get my little timer out.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> SPEAKER 5: Good
morning everybody.
Our team worked with a
dataset of websites collected
from the Cuban domain
by the internet archive,
we studied with big expectations.
We wanted to work on
a period of 14 months,
and detect all media
events in this dataset.
In the end, we worked
on one day, one event.
But we had lots of fun solving
the problem, the many problems
that we were confronted with.
So, we decided to work
on understanding how
Barrack Obama's visit
to Cuba last March was
covered in the news in Cuba.
And compare pro-Cuban regime
media with Cuban media in exile.
So, we decided to also
narrow down our sample
to the major Cuban newspaper called
"Granma" which is the official voice
of the communist party assuming
that, in the context of freedom
of the press in Cuba, the other news
outlets would likely repeat the same
arguments as "Granma."
And the other news source that
we used is a newspaper called
"el Nuevo Herald" which
is based in Miami.
So, we started to work with WARC
files, which are very heavy files
and we encountered
technical problems doing that,
so we find another solution which
is that we scraped from the web all
of the webpages that we
wanted from these two sources,
and we organized them in
a database that allowed us
to do some text processing analysis.
Except it didn't work
so well, of course.
We had problem with
collecting dates.
So, for "Granma" it was very easy
because the date was in the URL,
so that was very plain and simple.
But with "el Nuevo Herald"
the date was not in the URL,
so we thought we were going to
crawl the text and, oops sorry,
and then find the, and then assume
that the date will be
always on top of the title.
But it was not the case, the
date was moving on the page,
so we had to find a way to
find the pattern of the date
in the HTML that we extracted.
So, okay. So, then we
worked on entity linking
to find semantic similarities.
Text processing to find mentions
and co-occurrences of words,
such as US, Cuba, Obama, and Castro.
And we used Gephi to visualize the
results in the form of a graph.
And then we managed
to produce one graph
that is a final graph
on the left here.
And instead of taking a top down
approach of trying to impose a set
at least of words that
we wanted to find,
we favored an adaptive bottom-up
approach, because we wanted
to let the data talk to us.
So, we defined the
event of the visit
as a co-occurrence graph centered
around prominent entities.
And one of the other challenge.
One minute?
Okay. Huh?
Zero. Okay.
And this is what we would have
liked to do, which is a timeline,
and we wanted to detect similarities
in events over a period of time.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> IAN MILLIGAN: It's incredible
what they can do in two days
and what they can do
in three minutes.
So, our next team here, I
Know What You Hid Last Summer.
>> SPEAKER 6: Well, so for our
project we came together around sort
of the nebulous concept of what
are the ethical implications
of using web archives and
working with web archives,
and then we realized we had
two days, and we realized
that we also wanted
to work with data.
So, our story is as
much about the process
and the interdisciplinary
work, and what happens
when an information scientist,
communications, web sciences,
computer science comes together
and tries to make a project.
So, instead of sort of having a
more of a theoretical expression
of our project we decided to sort
of express the ethics and sort
of our approach to our project.
So, what we started, we used the
UK elections, 2015 Twitter dataset
with the hashtags GE 2015 and GE
from February 27th to May 8 of 2015.
And we limited the dataset
specifically to members
of parliament in the UK who
were tweeting during that time,
because we felt that this concept
of publicness of a public official
and the publicness of
their content, right?
And believing that sort of
an appropriate place to look.
And we're taking an ethical
stance, a clear ethical stance here,
in that the general population,
are we allowed to use their data,
what are the ethical
implications of that?
So, we're actually
specifically making that choice.
So, what we did was
we grabbed these,
we had this collection of tweets.
We sort of, we went
through and parsed them.
We extracted all the
URLs that were linked.
Because what we wanted
to do is see what happens
when we take a Twitter
dataset and then we layer
on top of that a web archive.
How do those connect, what's
the sort of flow on top of that?
So, then once we grabbed those URLs
we looked at the current status,
are those currently available?
Not currently available?
And then we searched the
internet archive for these URLs
to see were these actually archived?
So, you can think of this as kind
of the process the sort of top line,
you'll see from the 27th to the
8th of May, that sort of green line
with the floating tweet flag,
that's when the tweet happened,
but you'll see that some of
these pages were archived.
And you'll see that there
are various archives,
which are those red dots.
So, a tweet happened and the URL
might have been archived 20 days
before that.
It might have been archived two
days after that, another three
or four days, another
five days, right?
So, we have multiple
copies of that archive.
So, we had, of the tweets,
we started with 2.9 million,
and we ended up with 12,357
tweets by members of Parliament.
Of that, 7,818 tweets had URLs.
We de-duplicated and
that's about 6700.
There are lots of get
out to vote tweets.
Come out and vote, right?
Of those, about 1335 were
currently accessible.
About 113 of those were 404'd
and so, what that sort of means
in our work, is that while linking
is a pervasive practice on Twitter,
and it's a pervasive
practice within UK MPs.
Also, we did a qualitative
analysis, about 10% of that content,
and what MPs are linking
to are the part page,
the party Twitter account, or
pages supporting a specific agenda.
So, part of this sort
of documentation of as
that agenda changes,
that's one of the cases
where archives could
become very important.
And we felt that a URL
is an integral part
of a social media post.
So, if you read the
social media post
without the link, that's
problematic.
I'm done [laughter].
All right.
[ Applause ]
>> IAN MILLIGAN: So, now we have
Team Turtle to share their results.
>> SPEAKER 7: All right so
there's a couple of jokes
for why we're named Team Turtle.
We work slow.
But we're steady.
And we also work in the shell,
as my colleague mentioned.
That's a programming joke.
So, but I'll just dive
right into it.
So, we actually received 145 arc
files from the Library of Congress.
And they told us right away
that this was really messy data.
And that we're going to have a lot
of trouble, so good luck with that.
The research question that we
wanted to tackle was which places
and topics the two candidates in
the 2004 election talk about most.
And did this actually correlate
with the election results.
So, our methodology was first we
cleaned up these messy arc files,
using the WARC-based platforms and
then we extracted the named entities
through the candidate
names and the state names.
And then we applied the
topic modelling, LDA, TF-IDF.
And we also had a semantic web
extension using the Google knowledge
graph API and also further
applications to Wiki data.
So, this is kind of our result.
The size of the circles represent
how often the candidate would talk
about this state or this locale.
And actually, if you hoover over
it you can actually see the topics
that were talked about most often.
So, hovering over there,
it shows Iraq was talked
about very frequently
by that candidate.
And extended this further, because
we're using topic modelling,
we can actually hook into all the
knowledge in the knowledge graph
and the related semantic web data.
So, what we created was a Python CLI
where we could query the
Google knowledge graph
and then what we got back was
actually this unique identifier,
which is the free-based nid.
And this is actually
the same graph database
that powers all those queries
you can send to Google,
such as where is the Library of
Congress and it can tell you.
This is the same data
that we're querying
and because free base is shut down
and we can't access it anymore,
the best alternative right
now is to access wiki data
and query the graph database there.
So, this is our project
in three minutes.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> IAN MILLIGAN: That was actually
two minutes, which is outstanding.
So, and don't worry we're
going to put this up on the web
and I'll let you all know soon.
So, then last, but not least
we have our winning team,
Team Counterterrorism.
>> SPEAKER 8: Thanks.
So, as Vint Cerf told us, the
internet was designed in 1973
to be able to allow anybody
who can follow the protocols
to play whether they're
a future friend or foe.
So, it's basically
viewpoint neutral.
So, packets don't really
care, you know,
what your intent is with that data.
And you could argue maybe
preservation should also be
viewpoint neutral and I assume is.
So, everyone in here is obviously
using the internet for the good.
But there are folks out there who
are using it to try to recruit
for violent extremist
groups across the globe.
So, when I discovered
a shared interest
with another collaborator here.
So, this is what you get when you
put together a political scientist,
a software developer and a
librarian, only in two people.
So, what we did was, so my
collaborator, Emily from University
of Washington brought her
great archives as well
as an ideology classifier
that had been used to try
to categorize all the cacophony
of different groups in Syria based
on text from their web
and radio transcripts.
And I had a set of tweets
that we'd been collecting
at GW using a social feed
manager, on behalf of the program
on extremism that is following
300 American and US based,
suspected ISIS sympathizers.
So, it's a pretty large
body of tweets.
There are a lot more
accounts than people,
because these folks
tend to jump around.
So, that presents its own
challenges in doing analysis.
So, what we did was we tried
to apply the ideology
scoring methodology
to this body of data of tweets.
And we were able to get
that to work on a small set,
but I think we need a little more
power to crunch through more data.
So, the other thing we did
was we used some basic,
just Python scripting to extract
the user mentions from those tweets
and output that as CSV of
edges based on graph theory.
So, if somebody is mentioning in
their tweets a couple other people,
so you have two edges right there.
And what we wanted to do was see if
similarity of ideology is related
to the likelihood that
they'll interact.
And that can help us understand the
relationships between these people
and how they're using
Twitter to try to recruit.
So, we fed those through
some R scripts.
And what we were hoping
to do was get to be able
to evolve the network over time.
I had a little fight with Gephi
it was just there's too much data
for one afternoon, we had about a
half a million edges in a graph.
And there's also the issue that
one account is not one person.
So, what we did was we
fed it into R and took
at least one snapshot to show you.
And it actually validated
what our colleagues
on the program extremism
have noticed anecdotally,
which is that there
are really two types
of users involved in these networks.
Which are, there are a few data
who are originating content
and a lot of basically amplifiers.
So, we'd like to follow up
and do this on a larger scale.
And you can see some of the
other things we'd like to do.
But we feel there's a
lot of potential here.
[ Applause ]
>> IAN MILLIGAN: More
importantly, this is just a flavor.
So, we're going to
put all the projects
up at ArchivesUnleased.com,
but that in your notes.
We're going to have all those
projects up very shortly
and you can get to know the people
who were involved in the projects,
what they were able to achieve
and I was thinking there's someone
from Wiki Media taking
photos in there.
Because he said, you know you don't
have a photo of young Einstein.
Well, there's a bunch of young
Einsteins here at this datathon.
So, if you're looking for great
people, you know where to find them.
Just before we turn it over we
might have time for one question,
I just have to do some
very important thanks.
So, none of this would have been
possible without the Library
of Congress for their
logistical support,
for their beautiful
facilities and room.
For their data, for
everything basically.
The National Science
Foundation generously supported
and made it possible for us to
bring in graduate students from all
over the United States to
come and attend the datathon.
Very important to develop
the junior scholars.
And the Social Sciences and
Humanities Research Council
of Canada provided travel funding
and food for graduate students
and post doctorial fellows to
come from Canada and from places
that are not the United States.
So, it really takes a whole Army.
You can see it on this slide
here, you know internet archive,
George Washington University,
Computer Canada,
The Web Science Trust, Rutgers,
the University of Waterloo.
It really did take a village
to make this possible.
So, thank you very much.
Do keep your eye on
these scholars it's going
to be an incredible few
years ahead, I know.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, I think we have five minutes
until I get kicked off stage.
So, questions for me, but also
questions for our friends on stage.
So many mics.
>> VINT CERF: This is partly
a question and partly a kind
of statement for your reaction.
I am so impressed by
what you are able to do
with information in digital form.
I know that sounds kind
of stupid coming from me.
But it's so different from
picking up a book and reading it.
And your ability to process
this information differently
from any other way we've done in
the past seems almost dramatic.
And so, I'm actually curious to
know whether you feel the same way,
that this is a completely new way
of understanding our knowledge.
>> IAN MILLIGAN: Any of
you want to take that?
Yeah [laughter].
Yeah, I mean I'm blown
away by what we can do
and what we can uncover
about the past.
And you know to me it underscores
the importance of the message
that you bring, that we need
to preserve this information
because if we have it we can
do incredible things with it.
So, complete agreement.
I think we have one over here.
>> SPEAKER 2: So, Les Carr
[assumed spelling] again.
I run a doctoral training
center with lots of,
you know with about 50 PhD students,
and we're trying to train them
up in these methods
with access to data.
What role, how can a body like
the Library of Congress be useful,
or the British Library, how can
they help us to train students.
How can they help students
to research?
What do you see their role as being?
>> IAN MILLIGAN: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Yeah, so I thought they were going
to answer all the questions,
but now I am.
I think, I mean the role I think
that they can provide is
really I've become a proponent
of in-person training.
So, there's lots of stuff
online, lots of training sites.
And you can run through scripts.
But nothing replaces the
ability to go to a place
like the British Library, which
has data onsite, has, you know,
British Library has
incredible staff who can help,
you know bring these
things together.
Provide computing resources, provide
people together and let these sort
of interdisciplinary hubs form.
I think you have that
at Southampton,
but most of us historians are
stuck talking to other historians.
Computer scientists are talking
to other computer scientists.
Librarians are talking
to other librarians.
And by doing things onsite,
bringing together excellence,
we can do things.
I mean the checklist to make these
events successful has really been,
you know food is always
important [laughter],
socializing is always important.
But you know really having machines,
like virtual machines to spin up.
Someone has a question, they don't
have to flux around with Amazon,
we can like, here's
the keys to a machine,
you know don't let
that limit your dream.
They're having a problem with
Gaphi getting a network going.
Here's a network scholar.
And just having that ability
for them to watch someone do it.
And you just see the
gears click in their mind.
And they can go back
to their home campus,
and eventually they'll
run their own datathon.
And it's like this virus that
will spread around the world.
So, that's my dream.
Yeah. Go ahead.
>> SPEAKER 6: I think also, there's
part of, institutions provide sort
of indorsement in some ways of
our work and legitimize some
of the exploratory work that
we're doing that some chunks
of our field might see as
unimportant or legitimate.
I also think that the view that
institutions like the Library
of Congress and the British
Library and such bring the long view
of contextualizing, provenance,
preservation, the connectedness
and also maybe help decrease
some of the sort of fetishizing
of the technical and also help us
sort of contextualize and center,
so I think there's a grounding
that these institutions can provide
that I think is really helpful that
as we innovate, it's also important
for us to get some of the
grounding from the institutions.
>> SPEAKER 8: I think one of the
other things that institutions
like the Library of Congress
and your institution can do are
to take the lead in helping to
resolve some of the gray areas
of the ethical and legal
issues in preservation,
or sharing this type of data.
So, I that role, you know
these institutions can do it.
A good example is what internet
archive also has done in some
of the areas that a few
years ago were gray areas
and they've just done it
in terms of taking lead
and going ahead and preserving it.
So, I think that's a role that also
the LOC and British Library can do.
>> IAN MILLIGAN: Well,
I think we're at 11:15.
And we're going to be on time today.
So, thank you very much give
them all a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
>> DAME WENDY HALL: You're
not taking this down?
You're leaving this here?
Yeah. Okay.
Okay then.
So, we move seamlessly onto
our first panel of the day.
Do you need?
Okay.
We move seamlessly onto our
first, I want to thank Ian
and Jimmy and Matt for that.
I think this is, we
were really pleased
that we could run the datathon
back to back with this event.
It's worked so well.
And I think it's so important
that as well as hearing
from the wise ones, we
get the next generation.
These are the future.
And these are the people that will
actually carry the banner forward
and do the most amazing things
with the data that's coming
out of these archives.
And that's so, so important.
And as we keep saying, it is
institutions like the libraries
that will be here,
and the universities
that will be here for
many years to come.
When we were at George
Washington University on Monday,
they made the point of how difficult
it is to do interdisciplinary work
and you know we've really forged
ahead with this at Southampton
and it's really difficult
in universities to get
to bring different
disciplines together
and this type of event can do that.
So, without further ado, I'm doing
to introduce one of my co-hosts
for the day, David Lazer
from Northeastern University,
who's going to chair this panel.
David.
[ Applause ]
>> DAVID LAZER: Thank you Wendy
and thank you to the library,
I think this is truly
an awesome place,
by which I mean it
truly does inspire awe
about the possibilities
of human knowledge.
And, I'm just going
to say a few words.
I'm going to keep it short and sweet
and then I'll introduce our panel,
or I'll introduce panelist
by panelist.
You know, I think a motivating
example might be the election
of 2016, right, which is
an extraordinary election
and if one were to write
up what has happened,
I think you would just say it was
implausible as a piece of fiction.
And you know that there will
be a best-selling book in 2116
when everyone has forgotten this
election to say, you're not going
to believe what the election
of 2016 was like, right?
And it is inconceivable that
one could write such a history
without extensive use of
what is happening on the web,
what has manifested,
what is recorded.
And indeed, the amount of
information and possibilities
that you have access
to are incredibly more
than one would have access
to in let's say the
election of 1860, today.
And so, in part, the
interesting challenge then becomes
that we can't really
save everything,
in fact in some sense we can
only save a timely fraction
of everything.
And you know I think because
I'm a political scientist,
so I'm not the historian, and
I'll be long forgotten come 2116,
but for me as a political scientist,
I think, wow we can watch,
literally in principle watch
things spread real time,
but we can watch snippets of texts
of ideas spread through
the internet.
And so, but that's not something
necessarily that can be done
if you don't record the right kinds
of information in the right places,
at the right temporal granularity.
And so, part of the question and
part of why I hope we engage today
in some fashion is the need for
preservation, but the preservation
of what, for what questions,
which is an incredibly impossible
question really in a way.
Because we can't even anticipate
what the conceptual questions will
be two years from now, ten years
from now, 100 years from now.
We can't anticipate the analytic
machinery that will be available,
the development of theory.
I think that to address
Cerf's question earlier,
you know how does the digitization
of things change things,
it changes everything right?
Because and I don't think we
can even imagine, for example,
for me as a social scientist,
what the social sciences
of a decade will look like because
we can see different things,
we will be able to
imagine different things.
And imagine and construct
theories in a way that's so removed
from social sciences
before the present.
And so, that's really the
intellectual possibilities.
I think I do want to throw out
just one more notion of archiving,
just while we're throwing
out just sort of the notion
of capturing what is out there
on the web is how do we capture
the experiences of individuals.
And I think that there
is the opportunity,
perhaps for what one might
call citizen archiving.
And we've touched a
little bit on this.
But you know, what are
people reading online that is
if you capture what is online,
doesn't actually capture
what people are looking at,
and who is looking at that.
And so, part of what I'd like
to throw out there is the notion
of a couple of notions, one is
how do we interrogate people's
experiences of the web in a way that
is then captured in doing fashion.
And some of that may
literally be asking people
about their experiences, but a lot
of that may be also capturing
just the digital traces
of individuals' experiences
on the internet.
You know do the people who look
at "The New York Times" are the
same people who watch "Fox News?"
Probably not, right?
But how do we know that.
And how do we separate and sift
through everything in a way
that captures our contemporary
understanding
of where's the noise
and where the signal is.
Because we know, like with Twitter.
I'm a big fan of Twitter
as a resource.
But it's mostly garbage.
I mean, you know, it's you know
is bots, it's heterogenous.
It's a lot of the analysis that look
out there, basically pools together,
you know humans; regular people,
journalists, politicians, and tons
and tons of bots, some of many,
most of whom you don't
know are bots, right?
And then just sort of
aggregating the analysis
like those are all
comparable things, right?
It's a problem.
Right?
And so there maybe things we
can do today in terms of sorting
through this, that will be
impossible to do tomorrow.
And so, how do we build the tools
that allows us to separate the read
from the chat, when there's you
know such a bad ratio to begin with.
So, I sort of like
the notion of someway
of interactively capturing people's
experiences and saving that.
Of asking people about
their experiences,
and a lot of this is
sort of a mashup
of archiving old school
social science methods.
And so, I'm just going to throw that
out as something to contemplate.
But, you know I'm going to now
shift to introducing, well,
I'll introduce our first
panelist, Jeff Bailey.
I think Jeff represents
the internet.
>> JEFFERSON BAILEY: Jefferson.
>> DAVID LAZER: Jefferson.
I'm sorry.
>> JEFFERSON BAILEY:
It's on the program.
>> DAVID LAZER: I realized that,
as soon as I said that but.
And now that it's been
taped, and will be put
up on the internet,
it will be archived.
>> JEFFERSON BAILEY: It's
in the historical records.
>> DAVID LAZER: That's right.
So, this goes to the point
of noise being recorded.
So, Jefferson Bailey
and I knew that as soon
as I said it to my apologies.
Since my last name is
always mispronounced,
even by friends of decades.
But Wendy did pronounce
it correctly.
So, thank you.
But Nasha always gets it wrong so.
Jefferson flew out
here from California,
from the Internet Archive, where
he's been working since 2014,
and as has already been mentioned,
our legion archive is one
of the leading institutions
for doing this.
It was way ahead of the curve.
And his work involves managing
numerous web archiving services.
And before that he was
involved in many initiatives
around digital preservation
in a variety of institutions
and libraries which is
enumerated in the biographies here.
So, I'm going to shift
the mic to Jefferson.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> JEFFERSON BAILEY: All right.
Thanks, David.
Okay cool.
It works. So, hi everyone.
I am Jefferson Bailey
director of web archives
and programs and internet archives.
And first, obviously, I
just want to thank Wendy
for putting on this awesome event.
Kluge and LOC for hosting.
And also, of course, Ian and Matt
and the whole Archives Unleased team
for doing the datathon, actually
the second one we've done
and it was really amazing over
the course of the datathon
to see researchers actually using
these web archives that often,
some of them I have crawled
myself entirely on a whim.
So, the historical record often
is determined by areas of interest
and I was like, let's
crawl every museum site
and people did some awesome
stuff with the museum data.
So, Wendy sort of challenged
us to do a little history,
a little method, and then
a little big picture stuff
in a very short time frame.
So, I'm going to try to run
through it pretty quickly.
So, folks that don't know
the Internet Archive,
we are a nonprofit library.
We are in a church in San Francisco.
It's open to the public.
Please come by if you're in town.
And we have been around, this
is our 20-year anniversary.
So, there will be some big
events later in the year.
And our mission is universal
access to all knowledge.
So, we are not just an
archive of web material.
We actually have lots
of digital content.
You'll see all the stats there.
The one, of course, most relevant
to our talk today is our web archive
which is about to hit
50 billion captures.
So, we've been doing it
since the beginning in 1996.
We get about a billion captures,
a capture is just a web resource,
per week, and a little
over a petabyte per year
in web data specifically.
So, we do have 25 petabytes of
unique information of all variety,
and a little over a half of
that is the web material.
So, here's sort of how
our crawling and capture
for web content has
gone over the years.
Obviously scaled up.
I didn't actually put YouTube
on there, but YouTube should be
on this slide somewhere since it of
course, audio video, it's migration
to the web has really expanded
storage needs for all web archives.
So, our crawling I think
sometimes strikes people as being,
it's one big crawl, and the internet
archive just crawls everything.
And it's actually much more dynamic.
It's much more, I have this sort of
constellation metaphor in my talk.
And I'll cover a couple
of the different methods,
but it's actually, I call it
multimodal crawling strategy.
So, we capture in many different
ways, not just ourselves,
but also working directly
with partners.
We do run big global crawls, both
at a very wide and shallow level,
and at a very deep and
sort of well-scoped level.
So, there are global crawls.
But, other things we do are
work with national libraries
to capture country level
domains, so, CCTLDs.
So, we worked over the years with
at least a dozen national libraries
to get dot something, something.
To get sort of a big capture of
a specific country's web domain.
We have collaborative collections,
a couple of which I mentioned here.
End of Term Web Archive, that we
do with LC and a number of others,
which is capturing a snapshot
of the entire US Federal
Government web domain at every,
before and after every
presidential transition.
We capture things like
orphan domains.
People talked about the Cuba
collection, we just decided
to crawl .cu, just because we could.
Spontaneous events, of
course, we're doing crawling
around the pulse event and have done
it for all sorts of global events.
And the of course we work directly
with researchers, K12 institutes
and partnerships with
educational programs.
And those are both to get subject
experts to contribute seeds and URLs
for us to crawl and
also of course to work
with them I use of our archives.
Another thing I was really
enamored events talk about the need
for business models, and
especially sustainability
around web archiving programs,
internet archive does have a quite
possible web archiving subscription
service that's used by almost 500
institutions, mostly libraries
and archives, in the academic realm
to create curated special collection
of archives that they
can then of course store
and preserve locally themselves, as
well as provide access through IA.
So, those are capture
methods, access methods.
Of course, most people
are going to be familiar
with the Wayback Machine.
You can enter a URL and see
its capture rate over time.
Of course, the obvious example is
an early capture of the Library
of Congress website from 1999.
It actually holds up in
this sort of web design way.
So, props to LC.
Of course, there's other
types of collections too.
So, not just websites,
but type of web content
that you can then aggregate.
So, this is of course,
we just extracted a bunch
of animated GIFs of puppies.
Because I really truly believe that
the web would not be what it is
without the ability
to share dog photos.
But it also, sort of is indicative
of the creative expression
that's also on the web,
that we sometimes forget about when
focusing on the scholarly record.
Other access models
like the hack-a-thon,
or research partnerships
to get our data out there
and get people using
it in different ways.
So, that's access methods.
And then sort of technology
and infrastructure methods,
we are of course dedicated
to open source software.
Heritrix as a crawler, Wayback
as the piece of software.
And we are developing new methods
of crawling technology to deal
with the dynamic web
in java script as well
as more API based infrastructure for
interoperability of cross systems.
And so, when thinking about
opportunities and challenges,
we have this thing called
the do we have it at API.
And it's basically just a big
dump of all sorts of identifiers
from catalogs and ISBNs and things.
And we can just hit it and see
whether we have it in the archive.
And I thought that was an
interesting model for thinking
about what we have and what we sort
of accomplished in web archiving.
And what we don't have and what
are the current challenges.
So, we are content agnostic for
acquisition of web material.
It's print, it's audio video, it's
code, it's CSS all kind of thing.
The web has consumed
basically all methods
of digital information delivery.
So, things that were not ever on
the web, printed in digital form
and now just going
straight to the web.
The legal issues, I think they still
exist a little bit, but have been,
I think we've made incredible
progress, the whole community
over the years on this when internet
archives started, before my time,
but people were like, 'oh my
God, you can't capture it.'
And, 'oh my God, you
can't even replay it,
how could you do that,
it's not yours.'
But it is of course a
public publishing platform.
And I think advocacy around access
has really grown over the years.
Time travels.
Obviously, we have been building
time travel into the web.
There are lots of browser
plugins and methods for looking
at archival replays of web
content over time in a way
that is very familiar to
browsing the live web.
Collaborative models,
some technical stuff.
We do de-duplicate content in cases.
We do actually do and crawl
RSS feeds, every link added
to Wikipedia, every blogger entry.
Lots of other methods that
we get automatic URL feeds
that go right into the crawlers.
And lots of automation
around crawling activities.
So, the web has become much more
dynamic, interactive, scrolling,
clicking, and we're of
course trying to build bots
to do that behavior at scale.
And then emulation which
Vint also talked about.
What have we not been
doing so great?
The web has been moving
of course more and more
to a programming environment.
It's not static documents.
It's interactions, it's
replay, it's behaviors.
And those are very
challenging to capture
with our traditional
archival methods.
APIfication, Wild Gardens,
Cloud Computing.
These are all mostly
inaccessible except
for with human intermediation,
or passwords or other methods.
So, that could really
limit the amount
of content we're able to capture.
Interoperability, we're
getting there,
but a lot of web archiving
systems don't necessarily talk
to each other very well, or require
very centralized infrastructure
to operate.
And then bulk access is challenging
at the scale in which we operate,
which is the multi petabyte scale.
And making resources available
for training and education,
and how things were captured
or how you can work with them.
So, in looking at these sorts
of areas of archival activity.
So, I come from an archiving
background, and I always try
to think of web archiving within
the traditional archival endeavor.
And you sort of have these three
modes of Selection, capture
and management, and access
which have not just code
and technology involved, but
of course communities as well.
And so, when you sort of
think about networking
between these different
areas of operation,
and maybe prescript your slide with
a certain model, it actually starts
to look quite similar to the
original technical diagram of TCP.
So, I've been thinking a
lot as a web history nerd,
of sort of the successes
of the internet
and Vint spoke much more
eloquently to this than I will.
But what made the internet such
the incredible amazing thing
that has just sort of
conquered the world.
And what can we, when building web
archiving, web organic programs
and technologies take some
of those key themes out.
And so, Vint talked
about the modulization,
the distributed nature, the
portability and flexibility of a lot
of the technical systems
and protocols.
I think the social construction
of the internet's evolution
was very important.
It was not just producers creating
for users, the producers were users.
And that innovation was dispersed
around a social community
that was both informal and
you know very feedback driven.
And of course, it was
built for scalability
for gateway between networks.
And for great fault tolerance.
And we can sort of adapt some
of these to web archiving.
We are trying to modularize
crawling, not just in the global
and little special,
and domain style,
but also the methods of capture.
Proxy browsing, traditional
crawling, user interaction,
archival replay, and capture
while you actually browse.
Making WARCs and metadata
more portable between systems.
The work is something of
a heterogenous format.
But then also building on
the lessons of the early net
for social construction, community
models, coordinated collecting,
collaborations with K
through 12 programs as well
as academic researchers, and
then systems of interoperability
and multiplicity of access models.
And so, I always try to
close talks with sort
of what are the big
preservation imperatives.
I think we wanted to go big and
keep in mind for this conference
at least, if we're going to
work to save the web at scale,
what are sort of our
motivating factors.
And I do think, obviously,
I think as most of us do,
the web is the most significant
communication platform of our era,
so we are living in a very unique
historical moment that has a piece
of technology that has changed a lot
of how, not just how we buy things
and interact and socialize,
but really the whole sort
of landscape of society.
It also marks an unprecedented
confluence of ease of publication
and ease of archival acquisition.
So, archives used to have to go out
and get things, or pay for them,
or work with donors to get them,
and it was very action driven.
And things were published and they
were sort of in some remote world.
But we're in this unique moment
where you can both make a blog
and you can archive it
within seconds essentially.
So, that's a very unique
characteristic
of our moment of time.
It also, I think as David
and Ian both spoke to,
allows for this unprecedented
plurality of representation
within the historical record.
You know, traditionally,
archives were very much motivated
by power, or wealth.
So, the folks captured in the
archives were often people that were
of power and wealth
and of a certain class.
And it was very difficult to
necessarily capture the day
to day lives of average citizens and
that's really changed with the web.
And then the last one is just the
sort of great motivating factor,
that as Wendy also mentioned
are our moment in time,
where we can archive its scale
and get this amazing
diverse record will be very,
very brief in the soft
of technological arc.
And that's it.
Thanks, everyone.
[ Applause ]
>> DAVID LAZER: Just trying
to get it right this time, so.
It's my pleasure to introduce
Richard Marciano of the University
of Maryland who has
been leader, a thinker,
and doer in developing models for
the preservation and dissemination
of human records on the internet.
And thinking about developing proper
cyber infrastructures for that.
And in his current role, he wears
the hat of a center dedicated
to exactly those questions.
The newly formed digital
curation innovation center.
So, looking forward to
hearing about those efforts
and his thoughts on the subject.
[ Applause ]
>> RICHARD MARCIANO:
Can you hear me?
Okay. And I'll put my timer
on because we're I think
there's a crunch here as well.
We don't have three minutes,
but we have a little more.
Oh, I forgot the clicker.
Thank you.
Okay. So, can't see
it on this screen.
Can I also see the
slides on the laptop, or?
Just over here.
Okay. So, my name is
Richard Marciano.
I've been at the University
of Maryland
for a little over a year and a half.
And in my prior life
I spent over a decade
at the San Diego Super
Computer Centers.
I'm a computational type person,
working on interdisciplinary
projects and had a stent of five
or six years at the University
of North Carolina Chapel
Hill in the I school.
So, the theme I wanted to
tease a little bit relates
to almost everything we've heard so
far, the notion of scale, and size,
and plenty, and the challenges, and
opportunities that result from that.
So, I'm going to talk a
little bit about what it means
to preserve in the age of big data.
So, don't know if I can
pull all these things off
in the few minutes I have but this
is a little flow here, looking down.
So, I'll give you a little bit
of background on a little context
on this new center,
collaborative center we created,
what its goals are, what we're
trying to achieve in terms
of preservation, what some of the
connections are with web archiving.
I'll talk next about a particular
project that's driving a lot
of the cyber infrastructure
development,
which is National Science
Foundation Project.
It's one of these new
big data programs.
This one's called DIBBs.
Data Information Building Blocks.
So, it's a software
development effort that tries
to build preservation
services in the cloud.
And I'll say a little
bit about that.
And then since we're part of this
session that's worded as the need
for preservation, I wasn't sure
if there was a question mark
or if it was a given [laughter], or
if we had to challenge the audience.
So, I'll say a few things
about how I've tackled that
and what's been funded, at
least in my spaces in the past.
I'll talk about a recent
workshop that was held in April
that captures a lot of this energy
and an upcoming future workshop
in December if any of you are
interested in the DC area.
And we'll end with just
an exploration of some
of the federal research,
federal R&D guidance and sort
of future directions that
were recently formulated
through several documents.
They don't directly address these
notions out of visual curation,
but if we deconstruct that and
try to pull it apart a little bit,
I think we'll find a lot of
really exciting terminology
that we can pull back and claim and
use to drive some of these agendas.
So, it's kind of looking at
the past, looking at the future
and formulating a few questions for
the audience, research questions.
So, the goal is to get to
those questions and depending
on how we're doing with time,
I'll zip through this thing
and we'll get to that.
So, this is a new center we
started at the University
of Maryland it's called Digital
Curation Innovation Center.
It looks at big records
and archival analytics.
There's some 50 people
involved so far.
Lots of students, lots of colleagues
interested in these issues.
External researchers with former
colleagues from the Library
of Congress, National
Archives, NEH, IMLS.
Several of whom are in the
room, who are all contributing
to this visual curation
network we're trying to build,
which is both educational, research,
and also has an infrastructure
dimension.
So, one of the pieces of
infrastructure I wanted
to highlight is something
we're calling the dataCave.
Not as big as the Internet
Archive, just a small thing,
but it's a peta scale archival
storage and analytics facility.
It's powered by MetOp
storage, Dell computing.
And one of the innovations
there is we're building.
It's part of commercial start up.
We're building an open source
archival piece of software,
it's brand new it's
something called Indigo.
It leverages no SQL platform
called Apache Cassandra.
And it's being explored for
long term archival storage
and preservation purposes.
So, the connection with web
archives is that we're using
that platform testing
and building it.
And we have some really
interesting collections,
about 100 million files,
some 72 terabytes of data.
This is work that was largely
done with the National Archives
and continues in other directions.
But, we've collected records
from over 150 federal agencies.
So, records of all ILC, historical
records, contemporary records.
A lot of these were collected
through crawling processes.
Very often very targeted
crawling processes.
We can come back to that later.
So, that's our test bed.
And the idea is that it's highly
un-curated, it's structured,
it's hierarchical, but
it's highly un-curated
and it's extremely
heterogenous and diverse.
So, it's a big bag of
miscellaneous things with thousands
of file formats from obviously
textual stuff, satellite imagery,
data bases, desktop, photos.
Name it, it's all in there.
So, that's kind of our reference
collection and we're using
that as a pretext to develop
computational archival approaches
and do some of the things you heard
about in the hack-a-thon that have
to do with automation
and doing that at scale.
So, a couple of words
on Indigo [siren].
Let me look at my clock here.
Hope that siren is not related.
So, built on Apache Cassandra,
it was originally developed
by Facebook, it's used by a
plethora of companies from Adobe
to Travelocity, T-Mobile, etcetera.
Highly scalable so it scales to
petabytes of hundreds of petabytes.
Of note, it's actually used
to manage distributed data
centers so that's our platform.
There's no external file system,
there's no single point of failure.
Data's automatically
replicated and compressed.
And you can store arbitrary data
objects and tag them with metadata
and create hierarchies and
containers, and all kinds of things.
So, it allows organizations
to deposit data objects
in a direct retreat.
And then there's a whole
mechanism based on,
sorry I'm looking down here.
There's a whole mechanism
based on triggers, and actions,
and so there's a whole
philosophy behind this of sort
of not self-archiving archives,
but sort of self-cleaning archives
and things that can do
a lot of automation,
so self-managing repositories.
So, very quickly, so number two, so
we're using this, all these layers
to design, this is part
of NSF collaboration
with the National Center for Super
Computing Applications in Illinois.
So, we're developing
essentially a series
of cloud based digital
preservation services.
There are two classes of
services, legacy format converters
and then there's a slew of
information extraction mechanisms.
All right.
So, what's been funded?
I did a little walk
back through time.
This is just for reference.
Polls, titles of all kinds of
projects I've been involved with.
I was more interested in looking
sort of at the signature of funding
in which agencies have been
involved over the last few decades.
And just in my own projects, some
of my own projects listed here,
obviously, it's The National
Archives, Library of Congress, NSF,
NHBRC, IMLS, Canadian
Shark, Homeland Security,
Mellon Foundation, Darpa, and one
of the themes here is preservation
of digital data, self-validating
archives, notions of automation.
If I place all these projects and
I try to pull out sort of themes,
I do a little topic
modeling inside that bubble,
you see the complexity of all this.
You have thousands of
data types, representative
of what you find on the web.
All of these different categories
of preservation from geospatial data
to digital humanities with
ethical considerations,
scale, looking at work flows.
On and on.
And a lot of what you have with
big data is represented here.
So, you might make a claim
that all the Vs are in there,
but you also have another calling
which is all the Vs for eternity.
So, how do you deal with
volume, variety, veracity,
velocity at times, not always.
And how do you keep that
around for a long, long time.
So, very quickly these
are references
that will be in the slides.
So, we had a recent workshop if
any of you are interested in this.
There's slides and videos in April,
looking at computational archival
science, and positing that we need
to sort of contribute
to moving this space
in this field toward what colleagues
are doing in other spaces,
computational social science,
computational journalism.
And that there's a place for
computational archival science.
And we're forming a new community
if any of you are interested.
Contact us, come and join us,
this is kind of building
a social network.
There's an upcoming
workshop in December
at the IEEE big data conference
in DC, where we'll be looking
at these issues of
digital records in the age
of big data, including web records.
Last couple of comments, there's
some really interesting documents,
federal documents that
were just released.
So, I've put a few notes in here.
I'm not going to paraphrase, but I
invite you to take a look at those.
While the funding agendas
don't directly talk
about digital preservation
or archival curation
and digital curation or
archival science per se,
there's a lot to build on.
And these are two documented
from the NITRD Group.
So, this is out of the office of
Science, Technology and policy
of the White House,
there's an April document
which is the federal R&D
supplementary budget for 2017.
So, if you actually; NITRD is the
organization that coordinates all
of the federal R&D investments
and makes recommendations
of what the research priorities
are for the following year.
NARA is on here, NSF is
on here, a lot of people
in the room are involved with this.
So, if you look at the
very latest document,
I highlighted sections 5 and 6.
These have been completely reworked.
And even 6 is brand new.
There's a whole section
on information management,
and large-scale data
management and analysis.
And these are really
worth looking at.
And I highlighted in red all of
those areas that are congruent
to the themes of the workshop
and research topics today.
And these are highlighted
as growth areas,
funding areas, futuristic areas.
And this is an opportunity for
all of us to work together to see
if we can tap into these
recommendations and make a mark.
And voice our voices.
So, a lot of interesting stuff here.
Last document and I'll
wrap up after that.
This just came out a few weeks ago.
Maria would probably
know about this.
This is federal big data research
development strategic plan.
Extremely interesting.
All these considerations
on authenticity.
So, a lot of the issues that
are referenced here have to do
with trust, which is a
fundamental issue for all of us.
What is trust, there
are issues of ethics.
There are issues of training.
There are issues of developing
the right kind of systems
in cyber infrastructure
and what that means.
Lots of references to
trustworthy digital repositories,
which came out of OAIS and
conversations, etcetera where many
of you have been involved.
So, a few questions
and we'll end on this.
So, looking at that
kind of landscape
and the things we're trying to
start here are a few questions,
maybe for the panel, maybe
for later on in the day.
So, do we really need
to preserve the web?
Don't laugh, yes.
How much of it?
All of it?
Do we use archival
appraisal mechanisms,
or how selective do we want to be?
What's the scale?
What does it look like?
Who decides what gets preserved?
Those aren't obvious
questions for me.
You may have deeper insights.
How do we get at the Deep Web?
And our first speaker talked
about some of those issues.
What are we missing?
What technologies do we
need to develop further?
Do people have the
right to be forgotten?
That's a big theme.
What are the ethics of remembering?
How do we leverage those things?
How do we actually preserve the
web as a sociotechnical system
and from a technological standpoint?
What are the strategies?
Are there things we
haven't thought of?
Who are we preserving the web for,
so the chair of the
panel talked about, well,
we don't know who the
future users are.
So, one of my former colleagues
actually defines preservation
as this sort of act of faith,
this time travel machine
where you're communicating
with unborn historians,
and future citizens, and you
have no idea how to get there.
All you know is the present.
And sort of you're
navigating and you're trying
to move forward the very, sort
of it's the shadows on the cave.
You're seeing shadows
and you're trying
to device what this glorious future
might look like and you're impeded
by all the limitations
of the moment.
So, one of the themes I've
actually gotten funding for and look
at is this notion of what does
software independent mean?
How do you characterize that
and how do you create
virtualization logical environments.
So, a few more questions
and we're done?
How do we leverage
the preserved web?
So, what do we do with that?
What kinds of analytics
are we going to look at?
What can we do right now?
What could we do in the future?
Who will be paying for this?
So, you heard several
comments on this.
What's the business model.
And then a more technological
theme that comes out of some
of the slides I shared with you
is how do we move toward building
systems of trust?
So, trustworthy complex highly
scalable distributive systems.
And what are all the
implications there?
So, there's a slew of
issues, and I've been working
in this field for over 15 years.
I would venture to say, this
is a contentious statement,
that we've made some progress,
but that we really don't know how
to solve most of these issues,
so this is still a research
questions, and it's wide open.
And it's why it's so exciting and
it's why we need to develop networks
and communities to continue
to tackle all these problems.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> RICHARD PRICE: Just to introduce
Contemporary British Collections
which is essentially the
British Library sound archive,
contemporary manuscripts from
1950 onwards, and published works
from about 2000 on and by published,
we included the UK Web Archive,
and we include the
newspaper collections.
What I thought I would do is not
tell you too much about the library,
but take this opportunity to
think hopefully philosophically,
hopefully not ponderously
a little bit
about the advocacy of preservation.
And the question I posed myself
was why are we still talking
about advocacy.
Why is that after in one way
so long, years and years,
in terms of published
output not very long.
Then Wendy's complete right it's
actually just a blink in some ways.
And to characterize that from a
national library point of view,
legal deposit as a French invention
in modern times, 16th century
and it comes into England
with effect in legal terms
from the 17th century,
but really enforced
by Antonio Panizzi the Librarian
of the British Museum
Library in the 19th century.
So, we're talking about centuries
of, in theory, legal deposit,
which is to bring every
copy in the land into one
or multiple places really.
The idea of positive implication
is very important to legal deposit
in the same way it is very important
to having modes of digit content.
So, I'm briefly going to call this
talk, goes without saying' it's
about advocacy, goes without saying.
And so, I'm turning that phrase
on its head because there's
so much implicit in what we say that
we believe in the web and we want
to preserve it, that
goes without saying,
but if you don't say
it, it's going to go.
There has to be an advocacy element
is actually really complicated.
And you come across mixed messages
that you have to tell to deal
with expectation, anxiety,
fear, idealism.
They're not all the same story
that we tell, or that users
and potential influencers can here.
So, for any category of collecting,
it's good practice to pause a little
and think why you're doing it.
Why you're spending this money,
and but for new technology,
it's particularly important
because you can make
future proof less decisions
that can be very expensive.
Thinking about why
we need to advocate
for preservation also
immediately gets you
into the kind of nexus
of complexity.
The web is certainly a layered
network, a kind of ecosystem.
And the way you cut it culturally,
it's an intellectual artistic,
social, political, economic system.
And that's before you
even get to the complexity
of the technical detail, which
is not detail in the sense
of something you can brush off.
It's absolutely fundamental
to the preservation challenge.
Within each of those
cultural challenges,
there's a different
kind of advocacy piece.
We've talked about
general elections.
And that was a selection priority.
We also collect the general
elections in our country.
But that's, already you
have made a decision
to prioritize essentially the way an
established political system works.
So, you haven't been collecting
in the same detail other kinds
of ideas, political ideas which
don't reach the mainstream.
So, it's very, very difficult
not to prioritize by accident,
or by things that go without saying.
It's important we keep on
interrogating our own assumptions.
I also want to share some of the
National Library difficulties
and pay tribute to
The Internet Archive
for actually beating the digital
library so quickly off the ground.
National libraries can seem,
and are in many ways slow.
And there are good reasons for
that and I wanted to explain some
of those I terms of advocacy.
It's not just that we're trying to
win over external and stakeholders
and people that are going
to fund us and support us.
We're also having internal debates
about the importance of digital
and how we can fund this.
One of the fantastic
myths, of course,
about digital is it's somehow free,
it's somehow free and we internalize
that even as information
professionals.
We internalize that.
And the actual fact, it's
very expensive to build
that infrastructure and
to bring those curators
and those technical people in.
And guess what?
Our budgets are not booming to
accommodate this thirsty, thirsty,
rightly thirsty wish
to take in more.
It's actually much
more tricky than that.
I think there's also, in bold terms
there's also a kind of competition.
I mean we're friends within
the library, but there's a kind
of competition between
the old kind of heritage,
some of which is actually
in my collection as well.
I'm talking about ordinary books
and ordinary magazines and journals.
And the new kind of what we think
of as heritage, but is not a given.
It doesn't go without saying.
There is a case for making our work,
heritage, a kind of new heritage.
And that's quite a
complicated argument.
We can say it's like the
heritage we're so glad we got.
It's just the same, sort of thing.
And in some cases,
that's sort of true.
So, newspapers which only
appear online are a bit
like the newspapers that we've got.
So, the Bernie Collection is a Civil
War, English Civil War collection.
Great, we've got those.
And now we can collect news
about Brexit E referendum,
not saying that's an
English Civil War.
Maybe it is.
So, we can do those
kind of equivalent.
And that's quite a
good way of advocating.
We can also say to our
heritage colleagues,
you know that stuff you're a
bit embarrassed about getting
and you've not done anything
with, it's sort of un-cataloged,
we've got the same
sort of equivalent.
Those kind of flyers, those posters
that you've never really had the
resource to catalog, we've got those
and we're going to catalog them
in a completely different way
because we have the data.
Well, the advocacy piece
needs public access.
Public access is the best advocate.
And because of our legal
deposit commitment,
although we have a whole lot of
stuff now in British Library,
it's very difficult
for us to share that.
And even when you get
into the reading room,
the render can be surprisingly poor,
and that's because web
archiving is like that.
You're not getting a look and
feel translation all the time.
But I've got tentative solutions
and there are really
sort of two or three.
One is for us to occupy
the old spaces.
And by that, I mean meet
each other, you know,
meet each other just like this.
It's really, really important
that we behave non-virtually.
And lastly.
[ Laugther ]
Of course, occupy the new spaces.
I have lots of other kind of
subheadings for these things
and maybe I can squeeze them I a
little bit later in the discussion.
So, occupy the old spaces,
don't neglect those.
Have websites on exhibition
alongside physical objects.
Don't forget about that.
It sends fantastic and
really strong messages
about the peril on each of them.
Last thing, be poetic.
Poetry-like time traveling
with the web archive,
that's an incredibly strong message.
It's much, much stronger
than more water-tight theory
and mathematical understanding
for a general population.
So, be poetic [laughter].
[ Applause ]
>> DAVID LAZER: A lovely
note to end on.
And now, finally, Abigail Grotke
of the library who's been working
on these issues for a long
time and leads the, well,
it's a long committee name.
The National Digital Information
Infrastructure Preservation Program.
>> ABBIE GROTKE: Actually,
we've been reorganized.
>> DAVID LAZER: Oh,
you've been reorganized.
Well, you know.
>> ABBIE GROTKE: Web Archiving Team.
>> DAVID LAZER: I'm looking
in archived version of.
>> ABBIE GROTKE: Just
Google me, you can find me.
>> DAVID LAZER: In any case,
well thank you Abigail.
>> ABBIE GROTKE: With a last name
of Grotke that's very
easily Google-able.
So, if you can spell it.
So, welcome everybody,
we're thrilled to have you
in our home turf today,
we don't often get
to host web archiving events
since I've been doing this.
I've been involved with
the web archiving program
since 2002 I think along with my
colleague Gina Jones, over here.
David talked a little
bit about the program,
but 'll give you a little bit
more of our history and how we got
to where we are and the
things that still keep us
up at night, because there are many.
We started in 2000
as a pilot program
to explore collecting web content.
There was an interdisciplinary
team including some folks
that are actually in this room,
I think Jane was on that team.
Looking at issues around technical
approaches, cataloging of data,
selection of content and of course
the ever-present legal issues.
We started with our election
archives as many organizations
who do this work do, the election
2000 and we were happily starting
to plan the election 2002
archive as another pilot
with some collaborations
with the internet archive,
in those early days as well,
when September 11th happened.
And we quickly realized that this
was something real and we had
to make it not a pilot anymore.
So, we went quickly into
production without really sorting
out what that actually meant.
And I can safely say that all these
years later we're still grappling
with all these same issues.
We haven't really solved
all of the concerns
that were even brought
up in those early days.
So, our approach here is a curated,
selective collecting activity.
We select content in various
events and themes to archive.
We do not have the luxury of an
easily defined US domain to crawl
like our colleagues
in the UK, or Iceland.
We're very envious of Iceland.
So, we also have a
lack of copyright laws
that really support
the activity so we,
and no legal mandate
to do this work.
So, we actually, we have a pretty
intensive and labor intensive
and complicated permissions
process that I don't have time to go
into today, but I can spend
hours talking about it.
We're very good friends with
the lawyers in the library.
The program is, we have a very
small core team that works full time
on the activity, but there are
people scattered around the library
that work on this and it's kind of
reflective of the collaborations
that we've all undertaken
with other institutions,
which his so critical to this work.
We really can't do it alone
and we need all sorts of people
and it's reflective in the research
projects that happen this week
that you need selectors
selecting the content,
you need technical experts.
You need the lawyers to tell
you how to do this work.
You need developers that
are supporting other
infrastructure aspects.
You need the storage experts that
can help manage all this data.
So, we really couldn't do it without
these different types of people.
And as Jefferson talked about
we collaborate quite a bit
with the broader community, like the
International Internet Preservation
Consortium, we were
a founding member
with the Internet Archive
in that organization.
And things like the end of term
government web archive and working
with some of our federal colleagues
who are here in the room on issues
around collecting the
Federal Government Domain.
So, again the permissions process I
won't go into hugely but we do have
to notify almost every
site that we crawl.
So, we have built tools around this
to help process all of these things
and send out permission
letters, and we get responses.
Mostly people like what we do, but
we do have a lack of response issue,
which I think is reflective
in other archives as well.
Most people don't say no they
just don't ever respond to us.
So, we do, that creates unbalanced
collections when you are trying to,
when there are types of sites
that you must ask permission for
and then they don't respond.
So, there are gaps in the
collection because of that.
Luckily the permissions
policies have evolved over time
and they keep evolving, and are
becoming a little bit more lenient
so we can do more, but we still have
to notify everybody,
which is a lot of work.
So, we have Internet Archive does
most of our crawling under contract
for the Library of Congress.
We don't really have the technical
infrastructure here to do that work.
But we do do some in-house crawling
using the same open source tools
that they are using.
We schedule our crawls under a
variety of frequencies depending
on topics and managing all
of that and trying to sort
through all the content that we're
trying to schedule, and crawl
and make sure we have is complex.
I'll talk a little bit alter about
some of the crawling strategies
that we've employed in recent
years to try to capture some
of that frequently changing content.
Our search is pretty
basic at this point.
My one visual here is our public
access website, which allows you
to search some meta data records,
that take you to our instance
of the Wayback Machine.
We are very excited about
the use of our data this week
and the possibilities
that we can now see
for using our data in other ways.
So, we look forward to the
future, working with researchers.
Some statistics about our archives,
we have about 90 total
web archive collections,
in a variety of themes
that we're managing.
Again, government sites,
law content.
We have things like,
obviously, our US elections,
don't worry we're getting
all those campaign sites.
We do things like collecting
web comics.
Some of our curators here in the
room who have selected that content.
So, we're trying to get a broad
view, but it really is those people
in the library that are interested
in web archives, who kind of get it.
So, there are gaps
in the collection.
We don't cover all subjects that the
library collects in other materials.
We have 22 websites available
through our public access website.
So, that's about 1/3
of our collections,
which we're hoping to improve.
We seem to get ahead in some areas
and then fall behind in others.
It's one of the things
that keeps us up at night.
We have about 25 active collections
that we're managing right now.
Mostly ongoing crawls.
So, we're getting sort of, in
the early days we had a lot
of collections that started and
stopped and now we have things
that go on, and on, and on sort
of with these long-term things,
rather than time-bounded.
We're bringing in about 15 to 20
terabytes per month these days.
And I like to, I have
charts that are similar
to Jefferson's showing
the amount of data.
We are much smaller scale we
have about a petabyte of data
of web archive content, but
really it's YouTube's fault.
I mean they really ruined
everything for us in 2005.
And you can see the numbers
just went crazy after that.
We're expecting to get about
290 terabytes this year alone.
And in the early days we
were, I don't know it was
about half a terabyte
in the first year.
In all of those collections we
manage about 6000 seed URLs.
At, again varying frequencies.
So, we're trying to use our tools
and our brains to manage all
of them, juggle all that
collecting activity.
And as one of my colleagues likes
to say, it's basically the scale
of domain crawling, but
at a selective level,
which is very complex to manage,
particularly when you're thinking
about asking permission
for all of those sites.
And we are very lucky here,
the management of the Library
of Congress is very supportive
and there's definitely
they understand the need
for preservation.
We have a steady budget at
this point, for crawling,
it does not cover other aspects
of the workflow right now,
which is one of our challenges.
But we are a more formal,
established program.
And I think we have job security.
I don't think we're going away,
no matter how many
reorganizations we participate in.
And the great news
is I know longer have
to explain what web
archiving is to many
of my colleagues across the library.
In the early days, it was the first
half hour of the presentation was,
here's what a web archive is.
It is not downloading
to your desktop.
So, some of the bigger challenges
that we face, it really gets at some
of what you've heard already
with the selective archiving.
What do we actually select?
We have, there's just
so much out there.
And what topics do we cover?
We have selection policies
that cover some
of what might be the things that
we do, but there's also trying
to figure out what our space is
and what, to avoid duplication
with shat other libraries are
doing, particularly in the US
when we have hundreds
of organizations
that are collecting content.
How do we know what we should
be taking responsibility for?
And there's just so
much, so much data.
It's so big.
And we are so little.
There are so few of us.
So, we there's also
this desire in all
of this massive data
to get everything.
So, to get quality, complete
captures of websites.
Think about how large
some of these sites are.
Some of these government sites that
we're crawling and hoping we get
that PDF that might be useful
to the Congressional Research
Service someday, or the one document
that somebody might
need in the future.
We can't guarantee it.
We can't, we can't do it.
So, trying to grapple with
those issues and make the case
that what we're getting
is good enough and good.
And the crawl, Jefferson's
already has talked
about this a little bit
there's been advancements
in how the crawler tools
are being developed.
Keeping up with all of
the changes in the web.
It's very difficult.
We often joke in the IAPC that we're
about 10 years behind
what's happening
on the web now with crawler tools.
So, little changes that Facebook can
make can just mess us up forever.
So, it's a big challenge.
So, let's see, jumping ahead here.
So, some of the things
we're doing to tackle some
of these scale problems and get
deeper crawls of some of the sites
that are of interest
to our recommending officers are
doing deeper quarterly crawls
of some of these really large,
like state.gov that's a huge site
and trying to get that
in a monthly crawl,
where you're just getting a little
bit along with all the other sites
that we're crawling
has been a challenge.
So, we're now doing like really
deep focus crawls on that content.
We're also employing some
RSS feed crawling modelled
after what some folks I Iceland
are doing for some news content
that changes so rapidly that we
can't get it in a weekly crawl even.
So, we're doing crawling feeds and
being able to fill out the gaps
in the collection that way.
So, we think that's, we've been
doing that about six months
or a year maybe, and that's
been going pretty well.
I have a few minutes left.
Some of the other issues, again,
around the permissions policies.
We keep hoping for changes and
that the site owners will respond
favorably, but we can't
rely on that.
So, again that unbalanced
collections is a big issue for us.
And it also creates a dataset that
has a mixture of permissions in it.
So, we find it difficult to share
our datasets with researchers
because we have some
content that's restricted
to on-site only and some that isn't.
And others that are perfectly free
to use no matter where you are.
So, all of that is stored
together in one archive
and how do we share that.
And again, our staff is limited.
We can only do so much and our focus
is really in acquiring the data.
We don't have the resources
to really work
to help make our collections more
accessible which is a really,
we hope to do that in the future
and that we can make
progress in those areas.
And we are truly inspired by all
of you here and all the people
that worked with the data this week.
It's very exciting to see.
So, I think I'll close there,
because I see the zero coming.
And I guess move on to questions.
>> DAVID LAZER: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So is the mic circulating
for questions.
In the back.
And if you can just say who you
are, and that will be great.
>> JOHN WIN: Hi.
There we go.
Hi. I'm John Win, I actually work
under Abbie here at the library,
but I kind of had a question
for the rest of the panel.
Just in terms of like the
threshold between automation
and human curation of this content,
just in my own experiences
knowing I've made certain mistakes,
and screwing up an entire
collection because of it [laughter],
where do we really find the sort
of point where we can hand this off
to an automated program, or
what are your sort of thoughts
on where we can find
that point in the future?
>> JEFFERSON BAILEY:
I guess I'll talk.
That's a great question.
I think there are efforts to
do, so I talked a little bit
about browser automation.
But browser automation will never
get to the scale of human action.
There are efforts to, and I don't,
this is not really scalable,
but I do think it's a potential
approach for transactional browsing.
So, if you are a person and you
can essentially flip a switch
in your browser, and it will record
to a preservation format
as you browse.
So, you obviously need
some self-awareness
about what you're browsing to
make sure that it doesn't go
into the archival records, but
I think that has potential,
but it obviously won't scale to
the extent to which the web grows.
So, I think it's probably not an
automation human question it's more
a multi-institutional question.
So, the more institutions that are
doing even small scale web archiving
will contribute to this
greater pool of archival data.
>> DAVID LAZER: Is there room for
harnessing the crowd for this?
Like getting people looking,
saying, well you know you're messing
up this collection and
having like bug reports.
I mean there's you know
that kind of thing?
>> JEFFERSON BAILEY: Yeah, there
are tools sort of in the browser
where you can, you know report
a bad capture, or tell it,
if there are images missing
in an archival copy it can try
to find whether those
URLs still exist,
they could have been not captured
for various technical reasons,
and then could be scoped
in during the browsing.
So, there's a little automated
QA that could be done.
>> RICHARD PRICE: I think public
intervention also builds advocacy.
So, you don't really want to get rid
of public selectors, or
curatorial selectors.
It's very good to have fan-based
selectors who are actually going
to bring a kind of loyalty and
enthusiasm to a wider project,
even though it may be niche,
the fact is that that is a very,
enthusiasm is leaky
in a very good way.
And it goes over to
a general populous.
And so, it's very important
that some things,
although they could be fully
automatable, are still personalized.
>> DAVID LAZER: Question
will go to the middle.
Will go number two
and number three so.
If we're going to archive
this [laughter].
>> MARIA ZEMANKOVA: Maria Zemankova,
National Science Foundation.
And I think it's about three
years ago when we had a workshop.
Richard Marciano was really
chairing it on curation.
The reason why we held it
because we wanted to find
out what techniques
would be developed
with what we had called
as painless curation.
Because without curation,
if we store it all,
I don't think it's very useful.
Okay. The report has been
published at ACM Communications
and I think there is a lot to
be learned from that workshop.
But I think one point that we did
not quite touch upon is archiving,
or evolving of the curations
across the centuries.
We've been talking here about
preserving the cultural heritage
and this and that, and what not.
We all of us know about
the concept drifts.
What about the curation drifts?
>> DAVID LAZER: You can pass it back
and then we'll ask the next
question later, so reactions?
It's just one you've got
to chew on a little bit.
>> JEFFERSON BAILEY: I do
think there's more potential
for crowd sourcing, as we mentioned,
we do a lot of spontaneous
event collections,
which are community's
submitted URLs, our sites.
And I do think that's much
different than the traditional,
archival appraisal or
acquisition model, which is driven
by an institution, or
by, university, or.
So, I think the curation aspect
has drifted into the public a bit.
But you do sort of have that
separation between the act
of nominating something and the act
of actually acquiring
it and preserving it.
So, it would be interesting
to think about how the sort
of curation drift could also
move into the preservation drift.
>> RICHARD PRICE: I
suppose I like the idea
of there being curation drift
across the older heritage
and the newer heritage
across the disciplines.
So, social scientists, computational
people linguistic corpus people
looking at 19th century.
Those techniques, very
useful to contemporary.
We want to have a text
and data mining community
that crosses all that.
And again, occupying the
old space, scholars meeting
up across the divide, we librarians
are very, very important for that,
particularly at this stage.
>> DAVID LAZER: Okay, I think
I promised to, yes, thank you.
And then, yes, you can be on line.
I just want to make sure I'm not
neglecting the peripheries here.
So.
>> MEGAN HALSBAND: My
name's Megan Halsband.
I'm a reference librarian here
at the Library of Congress
and actually I work on some of
the web archiving collections.
And kind of from a, I guess
curatorial point of view going along
with what everyone else has been
talking about, what are some ways
that you might see that
those of us who are,
you know maybe selecting content
can help more formally broaden the
conversation between institutions,
and between disciplines,
and between you know
professional societies?
Because it seems like there's a
lot of conversation that happens
on the same topics between,
you know historians,
and between art historians, and
between computer scientists.
But there's the cross
pollination of it and kind
of that cross discussion doesn't
really seem to happen very much
on a very formal platform, or
a formal way that I'm aware of.
I could be very out of it though.
And so, just some thoughts on what,
you know future planning might be
for that so that you know to help
librarians and to help those of us
who are working on these
types of collections make sure
that we are making responsible
curatorial decisions.
>> DAVID LAZER: Thoughts?
I mean I think part of
what my reaction is,
it's an interesting question of how
to engage the relevant communities
and get them in the
room talking about this.
And so, is there a space,
you know for example going
to the political science
meetings and saying,
what do you need archived
on campaign 2016?
Right? I'd be happy to facilitate
that, but that's just more
of a model of how one might engage
a community that is going to want
to chew on these collections
like tomorrow.
But of course, that's not
necessarily representing the unborn
historians that well.
So.
>> RICHARD MARCIANO: I'd like
to believe that perhaps as part
of your arsenal in moving forward,
you'll be fully weaponized,
that's a terrible expression, but
that there'll be other paradigms
and these are things that are being
funded, and they're being explored
that are part of interdisciplinary
conversations.
There are probably
not enough of them.
So, this is my shameless cue to
the folks from the funding agencies
to help us create these spaces
where we can bring these
communities together to continue
to explore these topics, such as
the meeting you mentioned several
years ago.
But, I don't know the
reference, sort of selector
of the future will have a
dashboard and will be able to do,
hopefully analytics on the fly
and you'll be able to examine some
of the collections yourself
and perform elements
of machine learning, and
discovery, and visualization.
And make more, even more
informed decisions at scale.
Looking at collections
and across collections.
And mixing, you know multimedia, and
historical records and other things.
So, there's all kinds of human
computer interface issues that build
on these conversations and would
benefit from these conversations,
and build on the integration
of a lot of the frameworks
and technologies that
are also very siloed.
That are funded through all
these different agencies
and programs, etcetera.
So, I'd love to see that happen and
there's some interesting examples
of what that might look like in
terms of future finding aids,
so futuristic finding aids,
and how to build those.
And what curatorial support you
might have in moving forward.
>> DAVID LAZER: Why don't I
collect just a few questions,
because we're nearing
the end and I see that,
and I hate to leave questions
unasked, but there's also
that curatorial role I have.
So, why don't we collect a few
questions and then people can react
to whatever questions
they want to react to.
Yes?
>> MARY FRAKER: My
name is Mary Fraker
and I've probably been watching too
many reruns of "Law and Order SVU"
but I'm wondering what is sort
of the ethics, the philosophy,
the policy, and the practice
regarding really repugnant things
like child pornography.
>> DAVID LAZER: And I think,
like I said I just want
to collect a few questions.
>> ROSEMARY SEGEROS: Yes, good
morning ladies and gentlemen,
I don't know, thank you so much Mr.
David, I didn't know we were coming
to the same event for
your cutesy this morning.
Bless you.
Thank you so much for
your presentation,
my name is Rosemary
Segeros, I'm the president
of an organization
called Hope for Tomorrow,
and Segeros International Group.
Looking at your presentations,
after the gentleman
for counter terrorism spoke.
I will see, I will talk
later, how do you look
at engaging international people?
IT people?
Groups? All you are talking
goes international, the website,
the election observation.
I do election observations in Africa
using my own applications I share
with you.
So how do we put this content
and what you are discussing
into the international level so
that we are talking internationally.
Because all you are
talking is used out there,
but many people don't know how,
even if they have that thing,
you want to make it universal so
that what you are talking here
at the Congress is talked in
Africa, is talked somewhere else
so that we are on the same page,
so that we don't blame each other
one day somebody did somebody,
because those smart
guys are not here
who do the hacking, or do bad stuff.
They're out there.
So, they need to get the message
and getting this knowledge
is very important.
So, how do we collaborate with
you all to make sure we bring them
for India and you go to
Africa for a conference
like this one and talk to people.
So, thank you so much.
>> DAVID LAZER: And
any other questions
on the left that we want to collect?
Anyone here want to get
a lot shot of questions?
How about on the right I
think I saw, any hands there?
Okay so we're left with
the ethical issues,
and the sort of more global
international perspective
to put it really short.
So, reaction?
>> ABBIE GROTKE: I can speak a
little bit to the global efforts.
I think part of this because it's
still very new, the early group
that formed around the
international community,
I mean there's a big European focus,
but there is an effort to expand
that community, work globally
together on these issues.
We all understand that the
web is not the US domain
and the Icelandic domain
or the British domain.
It's a global internet.
So even though we're all collecting
in different areas, we all are aware
that our archives, and we
all struggle with trying
to make this happen, to link
those archives and connect them
so that researchers will know
that we have all this
data gathered around.
There are efforts within the
IAPC to reach other communities
that we're not currently
engaging with and try
to expand our membership,
or collect in areas
where archiving may not be
happening, such as the Cuban domain.
So, I think it's definitely
a concern of all of ours.
The Library of Congress,
also, I didn't mention,
we have offices overseas.
So, we have a number of
international collections.
So, we are not just collecting
US content, we are collecting
across the globe in areas that the
library traditionally has collected
in so.
>> RICHARD PRICE: From
and ethical point of view.
Well I suppose there's also
a practical element to this.
Child pornography's probably on the
deep web, we probably won't be able
to get it in the first
place if we do get it,
it wouldn't have been actively.
We certainly wouldn't
actively select that.
It would come in through
a domain crawl.
And because it comes in that
way, we're protected legally
until we notice we've got it
and then we will take
it out of public access.
It would be illegal for us
to knowingly maintain it.
So, that's never happened
to my knowledge.
I'm sure in the long, long view
that the legal deposit libraries
and national libraries think
it will happen at some point,
but that's how we would approach it.
>> RICHARD MARCIANO: I think there
are all kinds of other aspects
of ethics when it comes
to collecting large content
and distributed content.
Very much like the
credit card companies
and all the social media companies
that classify our actions,
identify what we do,
derive knowledge
from what we browse,
what we look at.
We're reaching the point where
you can take several cultural,
historical archival
sources and start to find
and reveal really interesting
things that may need
to problematic ethical
findings in the data.
So, you can reveal sort of the,
you know, the hidden information,
correlate it, bring it back
together, de-identify people,
places, events that were
not meant to be shared.
So, this is a side effect I guess
of the technology of crawling.
It may not happen in one swoop,
but it's not that hard to do.
One of the collections in the
DCIC lab we were looking at,
which included conversations with
former inmates and survivors was,
for example was looking
at Second World War,
Japanese American internment
camp data.
And one of our computational
interventions was precisely
to link all the people, the events.
These were stazi-like accusations
of alleged misdeeds while
people were prisoners.
Many of them invented or imaginary.
So, you start putting
these things together
and you use modern analytics,
or commercial style analytics
and you're rebuilding
as we saw in some
of the student hack-a-thon projects,
you're revealing social networks,
and occurrences of
individuals and peoples
in the context of accusations.
It is very, very problematic.
So, there's this whole other layer
of how you very quickly stumble
into all kinds of ethical
dilemmas and implications
when you're harvesting a
large distributed archives
and bringing all this
information together.
And I think that's a
really important theme,
National Science Foundation has
a whole number of discussions
on the ethics of big data
and archival collections
in moving forward.
>> DAVID LAZER: Perfect
note to end on.
I want to thank our
panelist and our audience.
[ Applause ]
>> DAME WENDY HALL:
Thank you very much,
panel that was a really good debate.
Vint asked to point that as he was
going that it's really important
that we're focusing a lot on
archiving what's already on the web,
but we need to add more, by
adding the context, the political,
the economic, the historical
context to help people
in the future understand
what's going on today.
Right. Now's the time for a break.
Looks like it's lovely.
It's not pouring with rain.
This room will be locked for lunch.
Please be back here for two.
There are suggestions if
you don't know the area.
There's some lovely little
cafes just over the road.
Get some fresh air and please
be back here before two.
And come back and see
us don't disappear.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as loc.gov.